two
what is up
my people of the world it is august 10th
a wednesday another beautiful summer day
it's hot hot hot
out here in los angeles here is ethan
klein
[Music]
it's rewind time
[Music]
wow
interesting
interesting
that was a nice journey yeah now zach i
just want to emphasize i got a lot of
pushback asking you to keep it to 15
seconds it's uh 15 on the dot wow
maximizing that time
so i think i think we can lift the time
oh you want him i'm just saying i'm
saying that i let the people i let the
people speak on that one well we i don't
think we want it to be too long i mean
you know what let's give them let's do a
five minute
audio intro you got it
yeah
okay i want like a rock opera intro okay
welcome everybody
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn
stamps.com and liquid iv
how fun
love our sponsors guys thank you for
joining us we got a great uh episode
today there's a lot happening in the
world i gotta say
i know we have leftovers tomorrow but
i'm a little bit giddy about some of the
stuff going on in our world today which
is kind of just
kind of different you know what i'm
saying
a little bit different than usual
uh for one
trump just got raided by the fbi let's
[ __ ] go
you know i was listening to the daily
about that uh
it's pretty basic he stole
uh he stole top secret documents
classified documents
and refused to give them back and then
that was their only option to recover
them
what the [ __ ] is that it's trump
it is yeah
what the hell what was going on with him
was he imitating like
uh what was it was that at cpac or was
that um i think it was it's feedback or
turning point or one of those one of
those conferences yeah
i'm sure he was imitating something
very offensive
yeah so i i just i love how dude crowder
is having he's literally crying on the
air talking about how this is civil war
guys i know what to tell you the man
stole
classified documents from the white
house and refused to give them back what
do you want
so that that seems like it's it but
that's not even the that's funny and fun
okay but the do you think it's funny
that they're going after
marginalized minorities
like white billionaires white
billionaire former presidents is one of
the smallest demographics in this
country and
if
you think if they can't go after donald
trump they can't come after you dude
that's what crowder was like
first they came for trump they're all
coming for you next i was like what are
you talking about any [ __ ] classified
documents how are they coming for me how
are they coming for me next
makes no sense
you're just a lightweight
yeah but this will be a good fundraising
opportunity for him
but that's okay um well that's what
crowder spawned into yeah he was
tweeting like club
tomorrow we go to war and by war i mean
chilling my mugs yeah mug club baby
or this could happen to you
we'll get into the details of that
tomorrow but
the other great thing
i guess if you're american this is great
and again we'll get into more detail but
i'm just talking about all the good
things
that i'm excited about
huge bill
huge bill that's closing corporate
loopholes something that i thought i
would never see
15 minimum taxation
on profits of billion dollar companies
or more so if a company reports
billion dollars or more profits to their
shareholders boom at a minimum 15 tax i
know it's not that much but it's better
than zero and that feel good dan some
banana republic [ __ ] does that feel good
to
me
our precious beautiful companies
are gonna have to pay taxes
every republican voted against that what
are we nicaragua
every single republican voted against
that isn't that [ __ ] incredible
by the way huge
uh funding for
uh
climate change uh uh carbon emissions
curbing that that they're hoping to
reduce by 40 by the end of the decade
huge tax credits for electric cars eat
your heart out elon musk
[Laughter]
you know it's kind of crazy in
california they have a 7 500
rebate
for people buying electric cars and now
they have a 7 500 federal that's 15 000
off
an electric car purchase
it's kind of epic let's [ __ ] go who's
not going to buy that i'll hit that up
next time i'm in the market yeah
somebody in the chat keeps spamming
ethan you have a booger
how could you see it from there i don't
see
it
but i figure thanks for telling me here
let me let me get my it's gross yeah i
gotta do it shut up james two diligence
here
make sure you ain't got a bug thank you
no thanks for telling me let me look let
me take a closer look there's no booger
you tr
oh why are you trolling you troll ass
[ __ ]
ain't no booger i mean the rest of my
face looks give me that close-up
listen
there's a lot wrong with this image
it's not that beautiful maybe they mean
your mustache they just think that's
like a big booger smear but i ain't got
no bug
fat cam can we get some text over this
it says fat
fat bam
i'll make something thanks cam yeah
spruce that up
i'm glad that's a permanent fixture now
by the way
shout out to tiger belly and howie
mendel
and lots of other stuff like uh
now medicaid
can collectively negotiate the price of
prescription drugs which is so [ __ ]
insane but now it's a thing
saying that they couldn't they couldn't
negotiate prices i mean what the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
let's let's go brandon let's [ __ ] go
dark brandon dude what can you say
come on man i'm voting brandon 2024.
anyway it's all good things if he's
alive and the carbon emissions thing is
good for everyone in the world so that's
great
that's really great
actually ha it's crazy it's crazy i mean
it's like with damn something good
happened oh well and then also inflation
is down this month did you see that
it's lower than expected for the first
time since this whole inflation drama
started
which is [ __ ] awesome
jobs are up things are good let's go
brandon
[Laughter]
you know for once everything's not
[ __ ] doom and gloom brandon
you're right it is it is heartening to
get
you know tiny piece of uh as we descend
into uh total anarchy and
you gotta take the dubs
[Music]
take the dove you gotta you gotta bask
in the dubs we don't get the dubs that
often out here
you know
what's funny is that uh
[Music]
oh actually another great thing is that
uh seniors now capped at two thousand
dollars a year for their medicine
that's awesome that is awesome that is
another thing that's kind of funny that
they forced out the republicans forced
out or joe manchin
this insane notion that uh insulin
should be capped at
30 or something they're like nah
too far people with insulin
you can live without insulin they got a
call they got to cough it up
well there was also it's elective it's
an elective uh you see
uh when they were doing them all the
medicaid stuff bernie tried to introduce
a thing to also give dental and vision
to senior citizens or whatever
one one vote in the affirmative it was
bernie 99 in the negative
everybody said literally everyone but
bernie vogue
so oh [ __ ] that's awesome can't get it's
elect too much good news at once vision
is elective dan
seeing [ __ ] is optional is optional true
that's very
true um that's [ __ ] awesome
you know
but it happened
so that's this is a good stuff for
everybody
anyway but we'll talk more about that
tomorrow this isn't the political show
oh i guess it was three three i guess
two people voted with them okay shout
out to uh better than one
yeah shout out to whoever that was
their political career is over they're
done
get him out of there
dude bernie really is the only real one
i feel like in the senate it's crazy
well i mean let's if there really were
two others that voted with him credit to
them too but yeah but there you go i
just also i just love how conservatives
are like pro-life for fetuses but
they're like well you know [ __ ] well old
people can die i mean
we've already squeezed everything out of
them it's what they do dude pro-life
but but except for people that need
insulin
and i would rather die than do that yeah
i know you would
but actually we have a really fun show
today um we're having a call in from kit
boga
who actually
we're big fans of here really
interesting guy what he does is
is so cr is so crazy he will
take calls with indian scammers
uh it's a huge issue by the way i read
like 60 billion dollars got stolen from
people last year for by indian scammers
it's wild um and he'll he'll call them
and just see how much time of theirs he
can waste
and it's funny
it's incredible i mean these people are
having full on meltdowns screaming
so he's going to call and i i i'd love
to hear more about kind of his his
process
but he's a he's a great guy a really
cool creator so he's gonna call in a
little bit
um
and other stuff
which you'll just have to wait and see
oh alex jones that was another awesome
one
yes sir
do we want to talk about our harry
potter houses
yeah by the way what was with the black
craters that ryan cavanaugh ripped off
uh what what was what did we schedule a
call with them uh i'm talking to their
management we haven't we haven't locked
in a date yet
all right
he's out there running amok i mean every
day we don't address this is a detriment
to this i mean we could address it and
then talk to them later we can we can
talk about it
drive angry
yeah so we were discussing before the
show started
uh which griff which uh harry potter
house would be
and i thought there was some pretty
interesting results um yeah we've done
everybody on the crew i think except you
well and ela
well so there were the interesting ones
you were the only gryffindor dan
yeah i was the only one that got
gryffindor uh got out bro hero olivia
and cam were both hufflepuff such
[ __ ] you don't like that olivia's
not uh happy about it i get a hufflepuff
vibes i'm sorry olivia
uh
that hurts a little bit it's not a bad
thing no it's not a bad thing i
personally don't identify who are you
what do you see yourself as i i mean
when i took the quiz a long time ago
gryffindor but i think i'm slytherin
really you want to be slytherin
slytherin doesn't have to mean evil
aren't they like sneaky little [ __ ]
though just like
they're ambitious they're ambitious and
and and they've got their finger on the
pulse
really yeah
they are coming from my job olivia
absolutely not trying to kill me [ __ ]
horcrux
ian got slytherin that's funny i see
that ian a b
and love all gods
we're full of slytherin we're being set
on all sides by evil i'm not enthused by
the uh hufflepuff either yeah right yeah
i thought i always thought they were
like
lazy people like typey personalities i
don't think i'm that we've got a little
edge like yeah we're bad boys and we're
bad boys
fourth one
ravenclaw no there's no raven what is
ravenclaw sam got rid of oh what's up
ravenclaw shout out shout out to
ravenclaw what does that mean though
it's strong
i know the least about that one
surprisingly
i think it's like strong and smart
yeah but the way they set it up is
honestly a little silly because it's
like
everyone just wants to be gryffindor
you're honorable you care about justice
you'll fight for the weak
you're like nah that's not me
well ethan
don't you [ __ ] vote why am i
hufflepuff that's a [ __ ] see told
you that's hey stupid hey what do you
mean that's not a bad thing to make
anything
listen
listen not for you but for me it is
wrong
well you know how's that [ __ ] taste
i don't know why they're saying
why would they say hufflepuff you go no
i'm discussing before the show and we
kind of landed on hufflepuff gives like
theater kid energy and i'm not a theater
kid you and olivia
sang from memory uh a duet from hamilton
sorry i like hamilton i don't really
know
without the hamilton
i upon request
we'll let people know that but the fact
that you know that like a normal
hufflepuff would i'm sorry i know one
the one's only going up and i'm
hufflepuff
dude you guys are [ __ ] yeah i'm
ending the
take hufflepuff just like out of the
choices i think you know redo it
slytherin be part you know fun to party
with voldemort i'm gryffindor you guys
know i'm gryffindor sublime
come on
all right well whatever take the bad
pole
[Laughter]
puff
how dare you guys some fans
uh yeah but also yesterday i went to
disneyland with the kids and ila's
family and they have three young kids it
was great so much fun
saw lots of super troopers out there
shout out to all the nice folks we said
hi to nice noise
um
get that off of the screen
that's not true get it out take it off
right now it feels true well now you got
to put on the fat cam
what are hufflepuffs fat too
bad sorry
actually when you google i did this just
before the show when you google
hufflepuff yeah
makes me think of kirby
in the sidebar hufflepuff house
characters one of them is the fat
literally
pull it up
yeah the fat fryer yeah that's me guys
i'm the fat friar what the [ __ ] is that
is that is that a harry potter character
this is what hufflepuff's known for
y'all
shout out to our fat fryer that's me
love that
we got the best fans so supportive
oh
i guess let me do uh
ela and lena just uh just to round it
out so we've done everyone well
and lena yeah interesting gryffindor
slytherin
ela is ooh
i don't know enough about ravenclaw to
be honest
can we get some attributes i think
people
think they're like the artsy ones oh
okay
um
we love that kawaii's artsy well ela's
ravenclaw then all day oh gryffindor
[ __ ] you guys
[Laughter]
oh no ravenclaw ravenclaw's winning i
clicked it and it was like 90 griffin oh
it's a neck and neck though it's almost
tied between gryffindor oh my god you
guys listen this is my wife i love her
four percent hufflepuff i've hit her for
everybody out of spite every single
person i voted hufflepuff what is wrong
with hufflepuff what do you guys mean by
hufflepuff what is wrong with hollywood
no no no no no no what are you guys
trying to say about us that's what i'm
asking what the [ __ ] i like i don't
assume it's bad i thought they were lazy
and like type b personalities and they
don't do any magic they just sit around
and
don't do any magic they're just a bunch
of losers yeah everyone that gets up
above sucks
who in the harry potter movies are is
hufflepuff that's that friar that's it
but they don't talk about it in the
movie
there's no nobody cares about anyone
else other than gryffindor and slytherin
which you have to be a psycho to want to
be what about uh neville
these gryffindor neville longbottoms oh
wait gryffindor
oh wait
he does give hufflepuff interruptions
all right guys this is too painful we
got to move on
oh sorry i'm throwing one up for lena
just just to be
fair yeah all right everybody vote
hufflepuff uh
yeah everybody vote hufflepuff what is
lena um
i don't know i don't i guess i i'll be
honest i just don't know
to be honest i don't know either
who said why are you guys spamming
cedric
cedric diggory
that's probably a character that's a
hufflepuff wait since you asked lena got
gryffindor
you guys are full [ __ ] me and lena are
the only gryffindors what's his last
name
citric what
diggory
let me see
oh the hunk wait what what was he
oh it's robert pattinson yeah but well
he was he was hufflepuff yeah yeah oh
come on but he was in the movie for a
second and then he died yeah but he was
a hero
my boy he was a loser you're a legend he
was hufflepuff
oh never mind lena just flipped a
hufflepuff as well actually
wait wait that changes everything cedric
was hufflepuff
that guy was a [ __ ] hero dude and
also hunky
okay that changes everything for you
that changes word am i right
it changes everything for reals
do you guys saying i'm
cedric is that what i'm getting you're
literally robert pattinson
i am i am robert patterson's fitting
image
thank you guys
yeah that's batman by the way so and
vis-a-vis i am batman oh right true all
right looks like uh lena just barely
gryffindor by one percent hufflepuff
second place so there you go whatever
buddy all right let's move on enough of
the harry potter [ __ ] yep
yeah but disney is awesome man that
place is fun i gotta say it's so
expensive right was it like 300 bucks
now for a park hopper ticket
it's insane
but
i will say
when you're at disneyland
everything there is perfect like there's
not a there's not like one drop of pee
in any of the
restrooms there's no toilet paper
everywhere there's [ __ ] like everything
is perfect and it really comes down when
you look in the bathroom there's always
someone in there there's no trash it's
so nice there all the time there's like
a gajillion people that work there dude
oh my god and then we saw this uh world
of color it's a show that they put on
and the they have these fountains that
they project onto
remember incredible i've never seen
anything like that it's way better than
the fireworks
oh you have you seen that yeah when i
went for the first dude it's like
mind-blowing right yeah it's awesome is
it in like the tom sawyer island like
river they do one there but this one was
in the
new park california okay
by the ferris wheel
and it's like
i mean it's incredible i don't know how
they do it it really is something so
shout out disneyland did you do the uh
star wars ride the rise of the
resistance it was down it's always
[ __ ] down no it's broken
we were about to get in line
thank god that you know imagine being at
the front of that line and then it
breaks down because that's just like a
two hour wait
but there it is
moving on our first we feast snack video
dropped
and i'm so happy to announce that
me plugging the prolapse anus of howie
mandel made the cut
because when we shot this i was plugging
the prolapse and they said well we're
not sure like i'm gonna try to i'm gonna
try to make it work but can you guys
record a clean one for me
i was like hell no dude
prolapse anus or don't air it
oh but then elo talked me into it here
it is i want to plug something um howie
mandel good friend of mine posted on
tick tock a prolapse in it and
record scratch moment
roll that back it's rewinding
he said what
i don't think that ever works
unironically the record scratch
it maybe works a little better because
they had background music playing
and then it stops for the sake of the
joke so there's at least some sort of
contextual reason for it to happen you
know
i think the time of the record scratch
is is gone right i posted on tick tock a
prolapse in it and
i just i want people to go check that
out freaking massive prolapse anus and i
got like three million views so i just
want to say thanks for watching and if
you want to check out the h3 podcast or
teddy fresh oh you're welcome to thank
you guys for having us we had so much
fun i hope you have us again
yeah i didn't care about any of that i
just want people to look at the left
they're like what do you want to plug i
said well there is this crazy tick tock
how we just posted you all should go
watch ow
um
top comment is a camera angle that
doesn't make ethan look like humpty
dumpty thank you
there you go
can you show the like dislike people
were really hating on us here
i'm not sure we're really i know we have
a lot of haters out there but
yeah i mean i didn't know that they were
all on first we feast
uh here let me pop it open i have the
plugin to show it
let's see
oh that's that's that's a lot of hate
that's pretty bad yeah that's pretty bad
when it first went out it was like 50
50.
really yeah
on first we feast of all yes first we
feast like like that'd be like if i
posted a crowder's channel
i mean what's going on in first week
fees
and uh there was a when they posted to
twitter they tagged me and i went to
like it and there was just one comment
on it that was like pass
and i just clicked his profile to see
and he was like retweeting jordan
peterson and stuff
oh but i was like
what's the cross over here jordan
peterson fans and first we feast kind of
odd utter carelessness of the twitter
organization that's true maybe because
you were hyping up warheads
people were hating on me for that well
then i stand behind you because warheads
are the [ __ ]
it's controversial yeah i know it's not
spiritual but they i back you up on that
list they cut out the context i said i'm
going for this nostalgia this is in the
beginning and then you dropped og with
that [ __ ] cactus cooler my guy yeah
you guys are drinking cactus cooler you
guys like it i haven't tried it it's the
best soda on the market nice i won't go
that far but i do like cactus cooler
you should probably if you guys don't
claim what it is because
it's only here in southern california
it's this really is it really i didn't
know that here oh it's cold too okay i
see you guys watch them claim us for
watching my own [ __ ]
this is like
some underground deep level
soda and when i was a kid we would hole
up play video games and slam cactus
cooler i'm talking ungodly amount like
five in a day five in an hour
no way
we did
you know what's funny yeah we did orange
pineapple blast
i've never seen it anywhere but my one
friend's house
yeah you guys try it i don't know i
can't do that i'll [ __ ] hit some
cactus cooler avenue no no no no
the amount of sugar in those is insane
yeah that's what i'm saying
somebody said they're in reno they have
it there yeah you know it's probably
like southwest not just southern
california but like arizona it's like
the in and out of soda right anywhere
there's in and out they have cactus
right just from that entry there's a can
of soda how'd you not find your way to
the east coast oh there's
i think east coast has some regional
sodas that we don't get out here too
figure it out guys it's just a can you
can shut out
right moxie there you go
well anyway so that's up it was fun a
good time
oh i have to issue a correction
as a serious journalist it's my my
obligation to
set the record straight
the hundred thousand dollar night
with belle delphine wait we can we
corrected it during the
we were saying this might be fake but we
couldn't find a real website so i was
really confused by it
i see but we had covered it one night
with belle delphine a hundred thousand
dollars confirmed not real
apologies to everyone who sent the
hundred thousand
do not email me
you will not be reimbursing no no
reimbursement for that apologies
but she says she likes the idea so maybe
give it a little time
yeah maybe there's
and by the way i saw some comments that
people are like hey i know or i am a
high uh
high-end escort and they say
20
to 80 000 for a night is not
it's like the norm really i was like
holy [ __ ] dude
damn that's a lot of cheddar serious for
one night
[ __ ] anyone ready to pay me that um
do not waste that sweet milk
mm-hmm i'll milk you for a hundred meal
get me in there god
but let's be honest if someone offer you
guys
if someone was like i'll give you a
hundred thousand cash to milk my
prostate
maybe not yeah yeah milk my prostate how
much was that worth wait milk your
prostate not me
[Laughter]
are you asking if you yeah
oh yeah um hundred thousand
hundred thousand cash i mean
milking the prostate it's almost like a
medical procedure right yeah yeah just
put on some gloves if i could wear
gloves but he's gonna he's gonna finish
he's gonna come yeah i get it um yeah
you can wear gloves
the [ __ ] that is easy for me i dude you
would do that
i do it for 50. yeah oh there might be
some takers out there wow anyone in the
audience looking to get their prostate
milk by love 50k i joined him
i mean it's 50 grand dude come on dude
yeah i think i would probably even go
for a half about these guys are getting
in line to do it why are you guys
lowering your price i know
you're just sticking yourself your
finger upside down
you would do it yeah good for 100k wait
a dollar can you you can wear gloves you
obviously have vaseline and [ __ ] yeah
dude
for 25 grand really yeah me too
and it's i mean it is a sexual you've
got gloves and stuff but it's a sexual
character yeah
i'm a guitar player i got great fingers
exactly you're high end stop d value i
know you guys yeah yeah you have more to
offer than that 100k minimum interesting
100k
you do 400k
i would definitely think about it yeah
yeah
i would think i would think about it
what are we going to do about this you
learned a lot today
cam what about you
oh without even thinking twice about it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 would you
do
25. okay wait would anyone do it for 10
10k
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] dude it's like a
10-minute
process you don't know how long it takes
it might take them a while to get off
either way it's not going to take i
don't know it's it's easy money right
there i do i'd do it for 10. oh my god i
could almost set this up i could pay for
it
i mean don't don't get me wrong ideally
100k is is the way to go at a milkshake
ideally yeah but we're negotiating here
okay so who wants to milk my prostate
[Laughter]
10k for each year what about you ethan
what i do for 100k well what's your
lowest you'd go
bro
listen i
my price would be higher fair enough it
would be higher fair enough
you would flat out say no to a hundred
thousand dollars for yeah i would i
would i wouldn't i but but maybe
and this is with elo's permission and
stuff right i mean we're assuming yeah i
mean obviously
we'd have to get that approved how about
200 200 000
i'd say 250. that's a fifth of a million
dollars that's one-fifth of one million
dollars you would say no
i think i need like
i think i need like 5 million
5 million what the [ __ ] up just stick
your finger in an ass yeah just being
honest guys no
i mean celebrity i don't put that memory
forever i don't know the things i would
do for five mil bro
i know i didn't want to ask you guys
what you do for 5
[Laughter]
dude ian is ready to go
i'll give you a ride home in
perfect
500 and a ride home
yeah 5 million i'll finger someone's
[ __ ]
5 million you're lying you're lying you
would do it for a million i wouldn't a
million dollars no way you're looking
right now i don't have listen i just
i wouldn't i'm sorry i wouldn't okay
fair enough
my you know what i'm saying you got to
live with that memory for your whole
life dan
i'm a celebrity alcohol i'm a celebrity
bro
you know
celebrities they get paid a million
dollars to post on instagram yeah people
are fingering someone's asking well this
is five million who gets paid a million
dollars to post on instagram the
influencers they do like
ethan you're out here
they post on instagram tick tock on
youtube they get a million bucks you're
who is getting paid a million dollars
i'm telling you they do not at the car
kardashians
that's what i'm saying you're not you
know kardashians yeah youtubers but
youtuber gets paid a million dollars for
like multi-platform deals why are you
plugging howie mandel's [ __ ] for free
then
you're doing you're running a whole ad
campaign
what do we do about it ow
people are going to say i got my
prostate milked by ethan klein h3 not i
got my prostate milk that's something
they tell their grandkids it's a
headline they tell their grandkids that
i have small hands though would that be
a problem no it's even better
yeah because the prostate's not deep in
there right no no i don't think you
could probably go fish too man
what about putting your whole foot in
someone's ass is it the same what i feel
like that's a little easier yeah that's
less personal huh i'll do that for
500 500
oh [ __ ] that's funny
sharky's gift card
right home a shopkins burrito and a ride
home that's all i need
man
sam you have thoughts on this
no
yeah i just want to get a temp check
from everyone head empty yeah that's
fair ian did you
ian are you in
he said no 500 right home yeah yeah
that's a serious weigh-in
okay
i'd have to check with sam i mean if i i
guess if i don't have to come pick you
up that is helpful yeah
yeah
see i love that i love the camaraderie
you two have what a beautiful
relationship
let me ask you this
ian if you
milk someone's prostate for a hundred
thousand
sam came and got you
is that a 50 50 deal or is that all your
cash because you guys for the ride
well i don't know if you guys are in it
together she got to deal with you now
like oh she got to be dating the dude
who you know
100 000 okay what about this well i
think you know
sam he's maybe been watching some tate
or something i don't know but i think
i'd have to give her all of it you know
oh yeah
you buy me the car that i want
all is all is forgiven it's fine you can
do whatever what do you got your eyes on
sam i want the electric jeep so bad yeah
wait jeep the brand yes they put out an
electric car yes i want for real bad
wait i want to see that i love all these
new electric cars are so
freaking exciting and cool
yo an electric jeep that's fun
do you know what color
is that it looks thick i like the black
one but i also like there's like a dark
gray that i really like wait do they
only make it in the wrangler do they
make it in uh
they also have the sahara in the room
here i think this is the action yeah
wait do we notice the msrp on this
um it's
i want to say it's in the 50s okay i
can't take 15k off in california
right right that's pretty dope
50 yeah 57. almost 16.
yeah ah expensive they're pricey the
electrics they are
i will also take a non-electric
i just will take it so bad
listen what if um okay what if ian milks
the prostate and then you get half all
you have to do is smell his fingers
afterwards and done clean
this is really gross but
i mean she did have to
deal with the feek of fish yeah that's
not even as bad i feel like it can't be
worse than that i've already done the
worst thing
all right let's set this up there's
enough people watching i think there
should be some takers here so everybody
email dan with your uh cash offers
damn will facilitate block you
so quick if you email me oh someone just
gave 20 bucks for sam's jeep fun about
to get a g by the way that reminds me
somebody gotta email me
all the money yeah i'll go i have to
like
go through the chat log there's 20 for
sam's jeep fun so write that one down
20 clusters sam this is such a
this is such a fun thing you're going to
get that jeep because zach got the rolex
you're going to get the jeep
they would give it some
thank you for gifted
thank you for the gifted
well if you lease it or finance it i
mean
yeah it's not that bad um to lease it is
like fine manageable but even financing
it is so much
well yeah though you know the interest
rates are insane right yeah yeah i've
looked into it that's pretty crazy also
every car dealers having you pay 10 over
sticker right now
yeah that also is [ __ ] up
it's not a good time to buy a car
or a house or anything or gas or food
always got cigarettes though great time
to buy a membership to the industry
podcast they're trying to ban those too
zack oh yeah well menthol is right
aren't they banning menthols i thought
it was just like flavored uh menthol is
considered flavored is it
um
oh you just got another 20 from chris
for the jeep fun yeah damn
[Applause]
only only 59
800 left to go
it's not bad
holy [ __ ] guys here we go
guys what the hell
thank you you guys need to take after me
i'm driving out one thousand dollar car
and that [ __ ] is sick as [ __ ] dog
it's very liberating to drive a shitty
car ten dollars for something that's my
philosophy too not that my car is that
shitty but
well the first time i got like a the
first nice car i got was like a used
prius nice for me
was like a 10 year old used prius i
thought it was the [ __ ] when i got that
[ __ ] car dude
you know what i mean
and i was so you get all paranoid about
it getting scratched and stuff and it's
really annoying
and then they're well
yeah priuses are like expensive to get
repairs on too right
i haven't i don't know i never actually
did anything
yeah
oh god there's so many coming in now all
right we're gonna have to okay all right
sam you're getting that [ __ ] jeep
what'd i tell you i'm gonna get it
tomorrow yeah thank you for the gift
thank you for the jeep does that mean i
don't have to i don't have to milk
anyone think of a jeep no you still need
to no you still have to do that you're
gonna you're gonna finish the cross the
finish line for her uh ian you could
think of a gifted
thank you for the milking jrh nbr oh no
thank you for the milk just the right
height no bucket is required it's so
gross always says it
somebody donated five euros or no i'm
sorry uh british pound sterling and said
whoever wants a non-electric car
combustion forever hey man i'll i'll
take it
i'm kind of on that train dude
oh my god the money is pouring in for
sam this is unprecedented fundraising
i'm definitely missing you're hanging
out in the air i threw a little in there
for you sam damn yes i did
throw your hands in the air
i need to do this
go ahead olivia you know if you had just
handed her the five dollars
[Music]
i like the drama of it all right wait
olivia did you actually donate five
dollars you just did that yeah and baby
why would you do that because i want you
to get that jeep i want to see you pull
in next to me
only um
only uh
fifty nine thousand seven hundred and
twenty dollars left guys let's forget
that
sam temple thank you
for the gifted thank you for the gift
damn though this is some serious cash
girl
someone donated five dollars for my jail
bail fund yeah you're gonna need that
too thank you for the gifted the pride
thank you for prime damn okay
congratulations to sam ladies and
gentlemen wow who will have a jeep next
week apparently i will give everyone a
ride in it
yes okay donated that's fair
uh so there's only a hundred
oh my god thank you for the gifted think
of the gift penelope j thank you wait
someone really oh my god yeah here
penelope j
go get it girl thank you for the gifted
thank you for the gift
wow
wow this is a lot sam what the [ __ ] you
really going to get this jeep dude holy
[ __ ] i'm regretting not saying i wanted
a car look at this
sam temple ladies and gentlemen the cash
is rolling in the jeep of her dreams is
within her grasp
the money is rolling in folks all we
need is
59
730 left let's get those donations in
hey another hundred they got the gifted
annalise thank you for the gift thank
you for the giveaway forty two hundred
dollars
wait for real yes what the [ __ ] keep it
coming oh my god wait wait you might
even have like a a thou what the [ __ ] is
going on i'm gonna have a down payment i
know i got the down payment thank you
for the gifted the prime here someone
get my bag
sam grab my back
thank you for the gifted thing
thank you for the gift dude somebody
said dan you asked for a scorpion desk
instead yeah i [ __ ] up that was
literally to be fair the score was that
my idea oh no you did no no i presented
it to you you could have had a jeep i
gotta have a [ __ ] jeep wow the magic
is happening here today uncomfortable
ass chair that i [ __ ] hate now
wait stay here
sam step in the frame come on
thank you for the gifted
thank thank you for the gifted
thank you for the gifted i don't have
much but here's a hundred dollars
come on
thank you for the gifted
thank you for the gifted
sam
yeah but now well you're kind of [ __ ]
because now you got to get that jeep
well what's [ __ ] up oh my they're not
covering they're only going to cover
like
you're [ __ ] you got to pay for this
jeep now you're going to be bro
no i'm just kidding you're good
get that jeep girl
well we're going to have to do a tally
on friday to find out how much was
actually raised here because it's pretty
pretty actually ridiculous yeah i've
i've
stopped trying to track it i'm just
going to look after the show thank you
for the give me three thousand do you
think so i think i think i mean probably
it's been a ton so much wait can you
track it in the back end or does it not
show up yet
it
will show up at a slight delay but after
the show all of the super chats are
listed with the amounts and the messages
are off the rails right now this is
absolutely insane what's happening yo
but how much does a jeep like entry
level like combustion engine jeep
because you know that's kind of
expensive jeeps generally are kind of
expensive cars that electric jeep you're
not even going to get for a long time
sam even if you order it probably 30 for
like entry levels forever
i saw um i sat in one at a dealership
but it was like maxed out it was like 70
grand or something like that yeah but
that's like the only ones that they have
in stock or like that base model jeep
grand cherokee msrp thirty nine thousand
so like forty we're in yeah the gifted
it says starting the price uh so for
like the lower ones it's 35. that's
doable that's doable
right
thank you for the gifted yo
we gotta get sam that [ __ ] jeep
what's your one sub
thank you for the gifted
family family
family
oh my god another hundred bro this is i
even okay very sweet
evan elias young thank you for the
gifted what's your one sub and you're
the queen of the streets
dude taran done event thank you for the
gifted thank thing for the gift wait
are you able to calculate how much we
got here dan
um it does give a live counter i don't
know how accurate it is right now it
says 2.9 k
[Music]
but i think it's kind of delayed so it's
probably more than that wow
that's a down payment right sam yeah
uh it's pretty close sounds like it but
i'll be honest with you
me and ela got a new electric car it
takes a year dude we all had to order it
six months ago and we don't still don't
even get it to the beginning of next
year wow yeah yeah there's super every
everyone wants one right now
thank you for the gift super back order
wow
is this really happening
really happening thank you for the
gifted how are you feeling sam talk to
the people
you guys need to stop
this is too much
too much
that's very sweet
it's very sweet don't stop don't stop
keep losing keep using right now and
then and and ian do you have anything to
say
i'm i'm very happy for her she's been
talking about this jeep i'm i'm stoked
so is ian going to get how is he going
to get 50 of this jeep as you guys are a
couple right i'd hope i could get to get
a ride at least a ride in a uh a
prostate milking i'll give you 500 bucks
in a ride home
but is my going right wait ian
did you get a car or your car
what's the situation no
no he doesn't even have a [ __ ] car
here's the path to work today
did you really i didn't want to here's
the phone here's the funny thing is we
were supposed to go this weekend we were
going to go look at cars that's the
thing sam has a car ian doesn't ian's
been like looking and actively going to
the dealerships for the last several
months and now
sam's about to go get him
he's still going to be carving he's
going to have my current car yeah
yeah there you go yes yeah there you go
what's your current car stand have a
nissan sentra there you go ian carver
dream at le you know it's gonna run
ian's the king of buying lemons yeah you
know i hear that the the fourth
transmission is the real golden goose
yeah
my my car has been through four
transmissions it is oh i just got
another new one it has broken down this
is like the second time this year yeah
yeah so once a year if ian takes that
over it's gonna literally the engine's
going to fall through the bottom of it
yeah
yeah
thank you for the gift the green thumb
for breaking down cars
zach's going to take me though we've
been talking about it
he's like i'm going to get you in there
i'm going to get you a huge deal he
believes in his dealership no
he thinks he's he's dude i've gotten i
got a screaming deal on my car i've
helped uh sean paul out i it's i got
that [ __ ] you know what's the
strategy then
you
you gotta walk sometimes you gotta walk
yeah
and the majority of the time they'll
chase after you they come running after
you
not running but you know what happens he
call you does he come out and say yo
you'll come back in yeah let's make it
work
wow it's the jewish it's the chutzpah
you know you gotta have some hutzpah
yeah
but
it's a it's a seller's market i don't
know if you have the leverage you used
to
that's very true but we're gonna see
what happens
i believe in zach thank you he's good
let's go dude bring zach with you to get
that jeep sam
i'm going to
let him in there he'll
this is going to save you a bunch of
money
when you guys go buy cars do your
parents insist on coming so they can
negotiate for you it's so embarrassing
my dad always does that
doesn't do [ __ ] for the price
he ends up just schmoozing with the
salesman the whole time making it cost
hours to take hours longer
i would have expected your dad to be
good at haggling but
he's okay but like these these car
salesmen they're so [ __ ] insane at
what they do like they will convince you
you're getting an insane deal
right you're not they go walk out of
there feeling great and it's not that
great of a deal they [ __ ] you in the
back end when you they throw in the the
tire and wheel insurance they throw in
this then that you know before you go to
the fni the finance dude yeah dude
that's where they really [ __ ] you
dude that [ __ ] is intense when they put
you in a little [ __ ] room with some
dude
some finance dude yeah listen those rims
are the most expensive rims on the on
the road man
90 of our customers get that and they
never regret it i get the tire wheel one
guy i had the last car i got the new car
i got he had pictures he goes look at
the last rims man there's a picture i
got from our customer the room split
wide open 20 000
all you got to do is pay 50 bucks a
month
you're like that sounds
i mean [ __ ] being an idiot not to get
that
usually i'd say opt in for like the tire
wheel because if if you get like a
busted rim or like a flat tire you can
just take it to the dealer and they'll
fix it
yeah
jeepali
cheaply it's hard being uh like being a
woman car shopping too because they
assume you don't know jack [ __ ] for real
like they assume you're such an idiot
same thing with like car maintenance and
repairs
that [ __ ] sucks that's i hate car
shop it's like everything else in our
society has an msrp you got the [ __ ]
price yeah you pay the price
why the [ __ ] is it that when you go to
buy cars you have to
reach into a black box and hope you're
getting a good deal and not getting
screwed it's [ __ ] up dude i agree
i hate it
i like that it's becoming more common
these places that are like no
negotiation
uh sales my current car i got
from a uh from a rental company because
the rental companies all sell their
fleets after like a year or two yeah and
somebody told me about this and when
checked it out and it's just flat prices
no negotiation this is how much the car
costs and it's been a great car it's
been super solid you know one thing i
like about tesla is that from the
beginning it's been a no negotiating on
the price
oh really and it's just such a more
pleasant dude so much more pleasant
there's no they didn't even try to
upsell me on like
[ __ ] insurance and stuff
you literally you pay online
you go in and you get the keys it's like
thank you that's how it should be
yeah i'm with you
i'm over car dude i agree with you dan
like carmax is doing that in a bunch of
other places i got mine from carvana and
i just looked online as a online catalog
and they delivered it to my place too
like they'll drive the car to your place
wow the car donations are rolling in
what does it say on the back there dan
uh it's up to 4.1 k oh my [ __ ] god
yes indeed
4.2 with the hyundai is that including
100 i gave her it not including that yo
4.2 000.
i literally have to get it yeah yep dude
this is insane you best not pull up in
another car
yeah
we need a picture of you and your new
jeep she rolls up you have it tomorrow
she rolls up in a new nissan it's like
the same car
in a maz
maz cx4 you should roll up in like a
like 1980 accord with like a fat
necklace no that would be fat new
necklace that'd be cool dude that car
[ __ ] dude those ladies the hondas they
[ __ ] definitely
wow um well this is this is a magic
moment i mean this is the magic the
super troopers really on their ship
today
incredible unfortunately i have to
interrupt this magic moment to let you
know we definitely need to do our ads
and our guests will be here in about 20
minutes so we should so let's thank our
wonderful sponsors and then we will
prepare for our call-in
from a kit a bogo
how long how how long how long are we in
uh 50 minutes actually we got way off
track because there's all i wanted to
show a clip of tana and jeff i agree but
we we we're off the rails my fault these
guys started to freaking turn into they
turned on the faucet of money for sam
samantha is that your full name
it is yeah do you like being is do you
do not like samantha i don't like it
yeah yeah i don't like it do your
parents call you samantha no i no one in
my life calls me that so
so ian only the government
it's your government name
ian you should bust out samantha
sometimes when you guys are fighting
i'll do it as a joke just see what
happens
i hate that
just see what happens
wow the jeep you guys are out of control
man this is nuts
i tell you what a kid with cancer
couldn't raise money like this
let them [ __ ] die in my opinion
[Laughter]
there's a kid on another stream like
[Music]
i can't afford my chemo oh god no stop i
need a blood transfusion so bad oh no
it's the only way i'll live oh my god
thank you for the thank you for the
gifted
[Laughter]
we need that jeep
just a joke come on
that's true event i mean people donate
money to streamers all
just saying
at the joker church
[Laughter]
thank you for the gifted all right let's
thank our sponsors
first up is expressvpn guys
huge tech companies in america pay next
to nothing in taxes
meaning they barely give anything back
to society that has made them rich they
may not do a lot of giving but they sure
do a lot of taking i love this ad read
this is
kind of different copy let's see where's
this going ladies and gentlemen i'm
talking about how these tech companies
enrich themselves by taking your
personal data
freak that they grab your web history
your email metadata
and video searches to create a detailed
profile on you and then sell it off to
the highest bidders companies aren't
just selling products anymore they're
selling you
you have become the product to protect
your identity and your data i recommend
using expressvpn i like that dude
expressvpn to stick it to the man stick
it to the man big texting government
think about all the websites you visit
facebook twitter google everything you
do and say online is tracked by these
giant corporations using your public ip
address they can uniquely match your
activity and know your location
expressvpn makes you
anonymous online by camouflaging your ip
address and replacing it with a
different secure ip of your choice
expressvpn also encrypts all of your
data so it's protected from hackers and
anyone else is trying to spy on you and
what i like most about expressvpn is how
easy it is to use you just download the
app on your phone or computer tap one
button and bob is your uncle you are
protected you don't have to think about
it dude sure sure
so if you're like me and believe your
internet data belongs to you and not to
the greedy corporations then use
expressvpn
that's the answer protect your data with
the number one rated vpn provider today
visit
expressvpn.com h3 to get three months
for free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3
expressvpn stick it to the bad
yes
all right
stick it to the man
stamps.com
man we love stamps around here
listen we all mailing stuff
it is what it is
but
you should be using stamps.com because
it's basically the put mo the post
office plus
you're using ancient technology if
you're going to the post office let me
tell you why
stamps.com
uh is your 24 7 post office you can
access anywhere
stamps.com listen to this
30 off usps rates
86 percent off ups whoa straight up the
gate i mean you're almost looking at 86
off can they do that
they can because they get so much bulk
business they can negotiate the prices
down wow and that's thepowerstamps.com
and uh it's so easy to use we always
talk we talk about dan's girlfriend who
uses it they send you a scale
for any package any envelope
whatever you can weigh it and then it
prints the postage oh you put it on i've
got a a great little anecdote about it
that just happened the other day i'd
love to hear about it she's uh doing a
convention in seattle next week uh
emerald city uh comic con and
rather than carry on all of you know her
supplies and all the things she's gonna
be selling onto a plane
she went and shipped it
normally if you were to ship it with
like directly through fedex or something
like that giant boxes like that probably
be like two three hundred dollars to
ship it in time
stamps.com
75 bucks whoa
two giant boxes that's that's genius
yeah
it's way cheaper than 100
there you go i mean the discounts you
get are insane and it's the convenience
really that puts it over the top because
you mail you weigh it you print the
postage and then you either put it in
your envelope or put it on your porch
and they'll come pick it up
you don't have to go to the pub shop and
you get bigger discounts i mean it's
it's think about it dude
you know
come on there's a reason they've been in
business for 20 years
with uh a good girl 1 million happy
businesses
so don't mail and ship the hard way sign
up for stamps.com today sign up with the
promo code h3 for a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter the code h3
thank you thank you to stamps
and finally liquid iv
you know them you love them uh and by
the way shout out dr edds
iv is
good to go this is better than water
dr
i love liquid iv
they come in a package
and um
you just stir it in
and there's all kinds of different
flavors there's one for to help
hydration
there's one to give you energy it's got
caffeine in it i love the energy boost
one because coffee sometimes upsets my
stomach because i'm gerd gang
and it gets me that energy boost and
hydration that honestly
i feel like i don't get from coffee
um it's the hot summers are here so
let's be proactive about keeping our
bodies fueled and hydrated
they say one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water hydrates you
twice as fast and more efficiently than
water alone
they got great flavors
10 of them
concord grape lemon lime pina colada and
tropical punch
and like i said they come in these
little packs so you can bring them with
you
storm at home
and the price is amazing because they're
just in these little individual packs
dan what flavor you got there
this one is
tangerine
tangerine hydration multiplier i'm about
to get high oh [ __ ] dude
yeah i love it in the morning wait
i love it in the morning because you get
that caffeine you need and also you get
like really good hydration just hitting
a cup of water it's the best way to
start your way honestly
dan oh
whoa
dr ed says better than water
[Applause]
damn
love that
um yeah
i like the watermelon one personally but
all the flavors taste great
honestly here's also besides uh
hydrating you twice as fast it contains
essential vitamins
b3 b5 b6
b12 vitamin c it's got three times the
electrolytes as traditional sports
drinks made with premium ingredients
non-gmo and free from gluten dairy or
soy
it's all happening
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 15 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use the code h3
at checkout that's 15 off anything you
order when you
shop better hydration today using the
promo code h3
at liquidity.com thank you thank you
yes
hey
hey okay
okay
sam's getting that jeep thank you for
the gifted
sam's getting that jeep think about
gifted okay
sam
dude those donations are still pouring
in bro i don't know what to say what's
it at dan it's at 5k oh my [ __ ] god
where stan where's sam
she ran to the bathroom she left an
embarrassment she's going to get the car
by the way i heard that joke you're in
abc
you projected it you know what
and i listened you're right you did i
laughed i giggled you giggled
and then we had a moment about because
olivia is a you know she's a performer
she knows proper mic etiquette
proper mic editor he's not slithering
what'd you just call me listen you're
hufflepuff you're a theater kid you know
how to project babies
whispers that [ __ ]
so
uh to make me look bad
let me uh
just say
for
the record that the link is liquid
dash iv.com i say the wrong link no
it's wrong in the copy um so you
actually did what you were supposed to
do so go to the description it always
used to be liquid iv.com
well they've corrected they added a dash
a hyphen in there
oh that's so where the correct link will
be in the description yeah i i'm
updating it right now um but apologies
and thank you everyone for letting me
know that that's what i do so before we
get to quit boga i want to i want to
rush in some things uh jeff and tana my
new best friends talked about their
experience
on the podcast let's give some love to
them
how do you feel about h3 i think it went
really good i'm really happy it happened
there was it's crazy they're fans too
like today i feel like i was getting
like thousands of tweets from their
friends like welcome to the family i was
like this [ __ ] is a cult yeah i didn't
think about it you're absolutely goddamn
right
we ride hard baby
what's not
what let's not openly be a cult this is
okay it's jared leto enter its leader
jared leto remember we made fun of jared
leto because he's like yeah it's a cult
okay well maybe he had some good points
yeah i'm learning from the best
okay
it's a cult
happy joker church we are we are a
monolith nobody ever criticizes me
literally
[Laughter]
anyway tana queen [ __ ] go on go on like
two like i was so many people being like
i don't hate you now like i was like
damn all these people [ __ ] hated
people they hated it yeah they hated us
big time so like
she's exaggerating people really say
that i don't hate you now
no
i mean some people were like i changed i
changed my maybe yeah maybe i think
seeing them is like oh i think that
happened a lot with mike where people
were like this guy's an idiot and then
they saw him talk and they're like yeah
he's an idiot but he's also lovable and
funny yes especially if you like don't
watch tana's content you just know like
the the drama hits yeah all you've got
they're real people they're and and the
three of them are you know
their bestie material
i mean
look i told mike i'm plugging all the
brands i told mike the morning of
because he was all like he wasn't
stressed out but you know he gets he's
like what the [ __ ] what are we even
doing doing this [ __ ] he's like trying
to book a house in mykonos for the
vacation and he's like oh we gotta go do
this [ __ ] this stupid [ __ ] thing why
did i agree to this why did you get me
into this yeah and i was like bro listen
logan didn't have to fight ksi you know
and even in that situation he didn't get
the outcome that he wanted it was like a
uh this guy randomly called him out to
box and he went and trained very good
points they fought and it didn't go his
way but look at him now you know he got
out of his comfort zone and now he's in
a uh you got to give mike
company yeah you got to tell them that's
what i'm saying and at this point i'm
happy to announce that me and mike are
unveiling our new crypto exchange
a huge venture guys it's going to be
exciting we're going to happen
to take on monday take a duke of my bus
yeah yeah
[Music]
like this is stupid what you're saying
but all right [ __ ] logan's rich [ __ ]
now yeah and prime
you know maybe he was thinking i could
have a potential prime down the line
with ethan or something just like you
know you gotta just get out of your
comfort zone make a sports drink man um
no that's the worst it could happen yeah
you know we go in that's how i felt if
something bad happens we walk but i i
sense ethan's change he's got this new
energy about him when he wants to make
peace that's kind of what i was noticing
as well he seems like he's in his
peaceful father friend like picking
that's true he's enlightened i am the
all loving all benevolent
cult leader
ian do you have the overlay of bronzo
with his face cut out because this this
might be the time i love all beings
and i instruct all my followers to love
and kind
but if you cross me
i will destroy you
[Music]
but i'm in my love face
but if you cross me
like david portnoy right he's my true
he's my one true arch villain now
versus david portnoy
ryan kavanagh
i'm kidding of course i'm kidding
but they're right i'm in a peacemaking
i'm i'm in the peacemaking uh
arc of my life can i can i give out some
love real quick to um
i was watching some of jeff's uh his
clips and stuff and i just want to give
a little tip of the hat to his audio
drop dude he's um he's pretty good i'm
gonna say hey yeah real recognize real i
really recognize real what
he says his audio guy's good his sound
bite guy what happened what do you mean
good bites yeah like a week ago you were
talking i changed huge amount of [ __ ]
about that guy changed my mind
change my mind
i just want to give him a little tip of
the hat that was real that's a
professional courtesy yeah
that's a vegan use actually yes i just
want to give it a tip as i understand it
they just have these little switch boxes
though with like nine options i guess
but um it was really flattering to hear
uh what jeff said he says he has his
guys watch listen to howard stern and us
for that type of stuff um so that was
really cool to hear right so now you're
just throwing compliments even if it's
not right
what do you mean like
like do you believe that compliment or
you just feel flattered
both
right
well what that's we're all in our
peacemaking right i'm just i'm giving
him a tip of the hat tip of the hat
jeff's guy
sound bite besties
i legit thought you were talking about
somebody else because
their news
seven days ago you were like a [ __ ]
suck i couldn't change my mind oh yeah
and you and you clearly have i i believe
you
wow we are all turning a new leaf here
in the history pockets it's a new day
who who else should i make up with by
the way i'm curious like
who else do i have unnecessary beef with
unnecessary beef
i personally would really like to squash
it with jason nat that's exactly who i
was i'd love to talk to jason nash
he's still a loyal uh reporter okay
mike's a loyal apologist
[Laughter]
you know that's fine i don't care that
he's friends with david he's his own man
right
i don't think brother banks i i actually
think that other banks that would be a
really fun episode if you were to get
bankrupt we need to make a list we need
banks we need jason nash if you guys
have who else should i squash with
um
xqc
i don't think i don't think we i don't
think either of us really care about
each other that much yeah
i'm trying to think of like
the old
people saying trisha come on
stop it
stop it
go canary
that dude i have no beef with him that
dude disappeared anyways but i feel like
we actually did squash our beef at a
certain point it seemed like it came to
a reasonable yeah yeah i don't think
there's animosity between us yeah
um crowder yeah [ __ ] no
i think i think banks and uh jason are
good logan
have you thought about
it at all
like i said to mike i i'm open to a
logan paul thing
because my only criticism of of him
recently is the dink doink thing and i
think it's really cool what he's doing
with the wwe he's talented it's
incredible what he's doing there so the
bear
i would consider a logan paul redemption
arc all right somebody's a matt haas
someone said
i'm more i i'm less interested in the
logan paul one though to be honest than
like banks and nash sure
uh it doesn't somebody should have
little tracy on helen keller
helen keller [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh you're
right
keemstar you guys are kidding serious
suggestions only um we it's it's already
2 30. we have is he on standby uh i mean
he's just waiting for me to send him the
link all right so let me just you can
let me just set him up so kip bogo as i
was saying
super talented twitch streamer kit boga
on twitch
he has a pretty big youtube channel now
2.6 million
sometimes i'll just let his videos run
dude and they are incredible what he
does
let me read you some stats
about the staggering
quantity of indian scamming that
actually goes on now i
kind of learned about this stuff through
watching his videos and there's a couple
other youtubers that do um
really great work like this
um but listen to this man
as many as this is just from last year
60 million americans
have reported losing money as a result
of a phone scam in the last 12 months
bro that's 23 percent of all americans
what
that's shocking
uh one in three americans 31 reports
having fallen victim to a phone scam
before
that's crazy
the thing is it's easy to say like oh
these people are such so [ __ ] dumb
and stuff
but
these are pretty sophisticated these are
as you can say these scammers
because it's become such a huge industry
for them for example last year people
lost 10 billion dollars
so
they're super sophisticated
they have like insane social engineering
skills and like just different ways of
coercing people and you know what's
interesting everybody in the chat is
already saying
what we
were saying as well that well it's
mostly old people but
well check this out this blew my [ __ ]
mind okay
now guys watch this
the age breakdown is here this is some
research company so
i don't know how accurate is but
i'm just done with uh
harris poll which is a fairly
okay
average loss per per scam is
it's a lot of money
some people lose their ass dude
but going down to the age one
um
this is menver
some via
text message text message is 60 what the
hell
is that just like if you click the link
yeah like phishing scam whoa
this is by gender sorry to say the dudes
out there are sixty it's rock
women dominating once again women in
general holding it down with 38 shout
out
and of course our non-binary king and
queens are the slickest of all 2.3
obviously
so smart so slick
it could be the quantity right of not
bearing or people but i like to think
they're just super they're just really
adept at avoiding they're super tech
savvy
so here's what the thing that blew my
mind the most in the past 12 months
you know a lot of the
kid boga impersonates elderly people a
lot when he does these calls
and i assume that it was mostly retirees
who were falling prey to this but here
you can clearly see
the two biggest groups is 18 to 34 and
35
to 44.
um
that's incredible yep
and shout out to the men by the way who
are absolutely dominating and being
scammed
impossible men are doing impossible
things
they're taking calls they're falling men
are killing themselves they're falling
victim to scam calls
what am i gonna do
where would he be where would indian
scammers be without men
so what do you guys think of that the
biggest group is 35 to 44 does that blow
your mind
really shocks that yeah i mean i think
uh
if you adjust for
the amount of population that are in
those age groups it's probably
a little less skewed than it appears
there because they're just less people
that are 65 and older um demographically
but um
but yeah i think that it does go a long
way to dispel the notion that it's it's
just the elderly that are falling victim
to this uh it clearly is not dude 18 to
44. those two brackets are
fairly close in size yeah so there ain't
there's old people this is
you know people
in our age group who are watching this
podcast in us
younger people are more likely to fall
victim than older people it finds
somebody in chats at hustler's
university
that's true
did they
and yeah i guess that should uh
though you know statistically the
research says uh we have stats about it
here too actually um that about 85 of
these scams are run out of india um a
lot aren't
and it's not just
indian scammers where do you see that oh
it's in a different
i just have it here in the dock but i
was curious where they originate yeah
and i listen you don't want to be like
making assumptions about a whole yeah
and we should note that kip boga
actually goes out of his way to make
that point a lot that um you know to try
and avoid
it reinforcing racial stereotypes or
anything um but statistically a lot of
them are run out of india but there's a
billion people in india and it's in
england you know a lot of them speak
english so it's very much a right place
and and you know a lot of indians are
extremely impoverished so they you know
look they turn to things like this to
try and make money well there there's
one guy who participates in this who's
like a
i don't think he was born in india and
one of his parents is american or
something but he has like
uh perfect english and he his thing is
like i hate that y'all making it seem
like india is a bunch of scammers and
you guys are ruining the image of india
abroad
yeah it just because 85 percent comes
out in india it's just there's a really
powerful industry there a small amount
of people that is attractive because
they're you know like dan says they're
not making a lot of money there
in general and these people are making
what probably seems like an impossibly
large sum of money sure also there's
literally no enforcement if you watch
these videos you'll always find time and
time again the police do nothing about
it they're basically getting bribed and
almost
i don't think the police have ever done
anything in the in the case of one of
these
they do get shut down um uh that one uh
other youtuber his name is jim
jim browning's the [ __ ] man yeah and
uh i know that he has worked with
enforcement over there to get some of
these places shut down but i mean i mean
most of the i've watched all of his
videos yeah they probably shut down and
they just don't know somewhere else
exactly yeah yeah you're right it is a
drop in the bucket but there is there is
some enforcement going on
yeah uh jim browning this guy is insane
he hacks into their system
and then he'll [ __ ] like hack into
their webcam
and into their desktop and he knows
their names and everything about them
and he can show them the feed from their
camera he's on the file it's dude it's
so sick there's one video where jim
browning actually scammed them into
sending him 500 bucks you seen that one
yeah right no
yeah yeah damn them he got him to send
him like 500 bucks he's crazy
putting on my watch later there's
another dude that does it his channel um
he goes by pierogi is his name yeah that
guy's really good is that the guy with
blue hair yeah uh scammer payback i
think is the channel name no they're
they all kind of have this different
angle but they're all super super
actually what's interesting about these
anti-scammer guys they're all seem like
super super good dudes
yeah well i think they're doing a good
service because they're definitely
educating people of like how these scams
work and what to look out for and you
know hopefully
letting their loved ones know like hey
if you get a call like this it's not
real don't don't participate in this so
and you know and they all make it really
entertaining while they're doing it so
it's it's a win-win-win it's so it's
like the
it's like pranking someone
and you don't have to feel bad about it
it's like these guys [ __ ] with them so
bad and like it's the perfect villain
you just you don't you can as far as in
any [ __ ] you want and in my opinion as
far as that angle of the [ __ ] with
them kip boga is unmatched like the
other guys are great what they do as
well but kit bogus he's like [ __ ]
funny he'll so basically kid bogus thing
here as you can see
we made a little bit of an edit of some
some of his finer moments
just to show you guys because his thing
is
he keeps them on the phone as long as
possible to waste their time
and it's [ __ ] insane he'll have
people on the phone for like 50 hours
dude over the course of a couple days
right this this edit that i made is all
from one call
and what i tried to do is because you
know his videos are very long even the
edited version of the videos are like
two hours long so i just made kind of i
took one of his more beloved videos this
one had like 12 or 13 million views or
something on youtube
and just
kind of beat by beat of the scam tried
to get you know each part of it and i
also tried to get
you know a good demonstration of what
kit boga does his improv the voices that
he does and everything so so funny
dude he's such a good character actor
his old person game is insanely on point
yep
about here let's let's watch a little
bit and then dan you can work on getting
him set up uh he's uh he's in the lobby
now okay great so i told him we're
running just a few minutes behind but
we're setting it up right so let me just
show you guys and then we'll get them on
the line been calling scammers for over
three years now and although i've had
some pretty exciting and interesting
learning experiences and just all around
crazy moments this
has to be
the most extreme
raw
thing i have
ever witnessed
the entire call took place over a couple
days 10 hours worth of phone calls and
ultimately ended in a pretty exciting
display of anger
it started off like a typical refund
scam where they posed as a company like
microsoft offering to give you money
back for something you purchased they
lock your computer and then pretend to
transfer money to your bank account okay
do you have a username and a password
um
well i can't give you any personal
information over the phone
yeah now just enter the zip code
that's a little
that's my personal information
i can't say that
how much of money did you transfer
it says check your bank oh my god oh my
god forty thousand dollars what are you
talking about
i'm going back hold on hold on okay just
hold on
hello
hello
hold on hold on i'm unplugging the
computer so
i i unplug the computer that way the
transfer won't go through right
now
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i'm back
[Laughter]
mom what do you see on your screen
[Music]
i unplugged a computer that way the
transfer wouldn't go through i don't
want four hundred thousand dollars
[Music]
oh my god
no i turned the computer off i don't
want that money to go through i'm
telling you
we can't get it
[Laughter]
why are you yelling at me
is the computer
i am really sorry paula it's my mistake
should i skip to a specific part you
like
i mean
it's just an overview of the kind of
stick that he does that was super
surgery but today
she's actually in this one there's a
really [ __ ] funny part where he
he somehow convinces them that the the
gift cards that he went and bought
because that's generally how not all the
scams but a lot of them work by they get
you to buy gift cards to like the google
play store or apple store or something
like that and give them the codes and
that's how and i i think they then
resell them for money or something so
that's like the way they're they're the
best part about that too is they can see
his desktop
and he'll the thing that drives him
crazy that he always does he start he'll
start redeeming it yeah himself that's
at the end of this video and they
[ __ ] let's just watch that part yeah
yeah yeah you can [ __ ] lose his mind
it's so good
and by the way this is this guy's
invested nine hours into this [ __ ] you
can imagine
how desperate he is to get that uh code
right and i should point out too
because he has a lot of technical
knowledge so this what's on screen this
google play website or whatever is
completely fake this is all happening in
a box
that
so he set up a fake website that looks
exactly like the real one
um so that and you know he's programmed
it to accept the code so everything that
he's doing is fake he's not they're not
real codes right they're not real codes
or anything but it's very convincing so
he enters the 500 and then it says like
uh 500 added to your account right so
yeah good here's here's the meltdown
[Applause]
i'm purposely hanging up on him
we'll call him back in a minute but i
want him to think that his phone
disconnected and they'll just have to
sit there and watch me right he's going
to be he's still watching right because
he's i think his true power
he's so angry and he's got the thing is
he's got like um
i think he's got like six five hundred
dollar
codes so he'll redeem him and he's one
of them progressively more interesting i
might just leave the call right there to
be honest if we never talk to him again
i feel like we accomplished a lot in
that we spent 10 hours with them
we we
heard rage like i've never heard before
and it was an experience that i likely
will never forget so far i haven't heard
from steve oh is that it so wait i want
to hear
i think you would you had just missed
the part where uh okay
i understand what is going on
oh so now he's the husband of the woman
he'll do different voices and be talking
to himself and it's it's crazy how good
he is at it that's a talent in itself
all right here it is here's the
redemption
okay
for your density
are you mad
are you mad
why are you believing god
hello steve hello
are you [ __ ] are you mad
this is so you won't bother my family
[Applause]
why are you ready
because you want the cash why did you
redeem it
you why did you redeem me doing it
because
[Music]
[Applause]
calm down
it's insane dude
so anyway
kit
boga let's get some let's get him on the
phone here talk to him a little bit okay
i'm gonna let him in right now one sec
super entertaining
and so satisfying too because these guys
are such monsters you know there's a
situation where they're like
they'll pretend to be like okay good
because you know this is my last hundred
dollars and if i don't get this medicine
i'll [ __ ] die and they're like yeah
yeah no problem like they're just so
callous
there he is kid boga
welcome thank you for calling how are
you
i'm i'm well thanks you guys picked a
really good
a really good clip i think my video is
mirrored hold on
is that better yeah it looks it looks i
don't know
i'm just used to a you know i have a
better angle i'm just kidding but
so when did you start doing these kind
of calls like what where how did this
become a uh content for you
i think
probably 2017
is the earliest
or the earliest videos i
it could have been
uh 2016 but i wouldn't have been doing
any of it like and putting it on youtube
that was never my
that wasn't my original plan but
sometime
probably 2017 is when it got serious
and was there some kind of motivating
factor behind that like
to go after these scammers because i
personally didn't even know that this
was such a huge problem until i started
watching your channel and a few others
like yours
how did you find out about this whole
scamming phenomenon is this something
personal to you
yeah
i think
the general if i remember correctly
because it's been a while and sometimes
the story gets a little mixed up but
my grandmother had
dementia my grandfather had alzheimer's
and i remember at one point when i went
to check in on my grandma
she
it wasn't one of these scams but there
was a landscaper like a landscape guy
pulling out her rose bushes
and putting them in his truck
and she loved those rosebush like
there's no way that she would have asked
him to do that
and i started asking my grandma about it
of course he left
um
and i found out that she had multiple
internet
packages multiple phone lines basically
she had just gotten to the point where
anyone would call her and sell her
something and she would buy it there was
a lady coming to her house physically to
remove the viruses from her computer
even though
like physically to her house right
even though she didn't really use the
internet
and i think
i had that in the back of my mind um
and i saw a video called
hey it's lenny or hi it's lenny have you
guys seen that
i think it's called hi it's lenny but it
was this recording of an elderly
gentleman something something like uh
hello can you hear me and and he would
it was a recording and so when
telemarketers or scammers called they
would just play this recording and and i
watched some video on youtube one day
probably 2016 2017.
where a tech support scammer got really
angry with this recording and i thought
wait a second like i i was a software
engineer at the time i spent a bunch of
like all day on the internet
how didn't i know that there were tech
support scams and it i think it just
connected it to my grandma i thought if
she was still alive she would be falling
for this stuff or perhaps did fall for
it and i didn't i didn't even know
um
and that's kind of how it how it started
i felt like i wanted to
try to call and see what i could do yeah
the intro i think what's great about how
you do it obviously you're tech savvy so
how does it work you set up like a
virtual machine
so because they're they're connecting to
the computer they're controlling your
desktop
how do you do that so that they can't
actually
you know disturb any of your real data
yeah that's you you got it right um it's
a virtual machine
that
we've spent years
adding little easter eggs to and making
it so they can't tell that it's a
virtual machine because if you were to
set one up
yourself kind of out of the box
um
it'll just say when you pull up the
command prompt or something it'll say
virtual computer yeah okay interesting
yeah
like fake computer they just don't know
that it's fake
uh virtual machine so that
is what it's called we use
vpns to make it look like i'm anywhere
in the country
so i can pretend i'm in california ohio
chicago it doesn't really matter
um
i have a bunch of phone numbers so i
don't have to use my actual phone
uh
and yeah and the website is fake dan was
telling me about you've created this
whole web fake website to redeem codes
like what is the
scope of this whole like uh
tech
tech illusion you've created for them
what is the whole scale of that
we've done so many it's hard to keep
track there was a time where
so i stream on twitch as well as the
youtube videos and there was a time
where i would stream
and the community would come up with
stuff they came up with that google
redeem actually it wasn't even my
like original idea we were all just
hanging out one night
and talking about how they always asked
me to buy gift cards what could we do to
make them angry
and one way or another we were like what
if we just fake the google play store so
we
i coded uh google
extension basically like a plug-in for
chrome
that whenever i'm on the google play
store
it makes it look like any 16
digit
you know number it just says 500 dollars
was added awesome but the scammers have
no idea
and they get
they get really mad obviously so
so so is that the way you found to piss
them off the most i mean the
the way it plays out is just incredible
dude how you're typing it slowly
or pasting it i mean it's just so good
the suspense of it
oh it's been lots of practice for sure i
think
uh you guys were talking about like
i do predominantly
i find that being older characters
lets me get away with a lot more
so
a lot of times i will play
an older character
and
just play clueless like i have like i'm
i'm i i'm literally giving them money
right now i'm thinking i'm
yes
here's your 500
uh so that usually does make them
angry occasionally if they ask me to
wire money to them i just come up with
like reasons as why that didn't work out
so sometimes i'll
they'll ask you to keep the phone on
while you go into the bank so i'll play
multiple characters and pretend that i'm
the bank manager or something
and that the
i say something silly like well i'm i'm
here because i
like most recently they've been they
told me uh i i couldn't tell the bank
anything and to pretend that i'm a
secret agent
because
they know the scammers know if you tell
the bank
uh that you need to wire forty thousand
dollars out of the country
because you're a secret age right
so i ended up just telling the bank
manager like this is a special mission
uh the government hired me to wire money
and then i play the bank manager
explaining that it's a scam and then
this the scammers obviously get upset so
it's so good
really anything where they think they're
about to get the money and i take it
away from them yeah makes them upset
yeah
i have a question i mean you must be
somewhat infamous in these scamming
circles do these guys know who you are
uh some of them
do
uh
occasionally they they will
they'll say
something like
um i think i know who you are you must
be kid boga
but you i mean you were mentioning some
other scandals before i hopped on they
do the same thing where
um sometimes
i liken it onto
something like the boogeyman or whatever
some some mythological
um
thing that they know could be lurking in
the shadows and so when things aren't
going their way
or after i spend thousands of dollars
and redeem a bunch of gift cards
they're thinking oh shoot
is this real like is this
is this an old person is this kippoga
uh but i like to keep them guessing so a
lot of times i'll never tell them
um i used to at the beginning like in
2017 2018 i would
i'd be like i got you man like
uh i got you
but now
uh so my longest i think the record
right now is something like 44 hours
dude and so today
i talked to a guy who i've been
basically scamming for months
in that he's given me over 40 bank
accounts
to light
but he's been using to launder money and
i just keep feeding it to
like bank fraud people so oh so this guy
who's trying to scam he keeps giving you
new addresses
yeah and you know he thinks
how the [ __ ] do you get how do you how
do you get someone bait them for so long
that's crazy
i wish i could explain this that's not
normal
of the 40-something hours is not normal
but
he he thinks that i'm a crazy old man he
saw me on
camera if i remember correctly a recent
thing that i've done
is
sort of
deep fake my face to look like an old
man so when they pull up the webcam they
see
like an older oh [ __ ] person next level
so he thought that i'm i'm like an old
man with a couple hundred thousand
dollars because i have a fake uh bank
account
and
what i would do is there would always be
something that would go wrong but it was
right when they thought they were gonna
get the money so
maybe that's a
i need like a psychologist
to
go through it what is it sunk cost
failures that's it i think they are
investing too much time and they're like
committed now which ironically is how a
lot of people get scammed for so much
money too i've heard people who get
scammed describe it like i'm in so deep
now i'm just going to keep sending money
and hope that it's real even though i
suspect it might be fake you know
oh interesting yeah interesting i've
heard a similar sentiment where
someone who had fallen for one of those
irs scams back in the day where they
would say you owe
like eight thousand dollars for back
taxes
that they had they had gone to the local
police and said
that somebody came to my door
and said they were with the irs
uh because that sounds a little bit
better
but in reality it was just a phone call
so maybe it's similar to that yeah
um so
have you see i'm curious um
have you seen uh i know you you know who
jim browning is you know how he like
hacks into their [ __ ]
yeah is that something like how does he
take it that far do you do you have any
ambitions to keep [ __ ] with them as
deep and as [ __ ] up as possible
i think i just stay i have a little bit
different style yeah i tend to be
more on the
like put them through absurd situations
see how long i can keep them distracted
partially because my original
thought when i
first started was well
if i kept them on the phone for 10
minutes
that was 10 minutes that they weren't
talking to someone else's grandma it was
a very
and maybe it's a little thing right
um but that's how i started
and then as it grew i realized well if i
make
if i make a serious video i tried to
make some
you know
like statistics and explanations about
scams people didn't really like to watch
them
so
if i make a funny video and it makes
gamers mad lots of people like to watch
it and at the end of the day i think the
more people that know about these scams
the better yeah definitely um i yeah
respect what jim and a lot of the other
scam-baiters are doing at the end of the
day
we just have different
maybe uh strategies yeah
your thing is keeping them
yeah your thing which i love is keeping
them on the phone or just wasting as
much of their time as possible which is
just so [ __ ] fun yeah
and i i realized too as i
learned uh
i guess how to
and i think that day i basically scanned
them right like i have their
i know their scripts better than than
they do at this point so sometimes i
just use their own script against them
but um
i've also learned that i can
get them to give me things like bank
accounts and and information that can be
useful to
for for
um like fraud professionals law
enforcement when they give you these
bank accounts and you report them do you
know if they're being shut down if
anything's happening do you have any way
to know that
yeah well some banks are
more forthcoming than others like i
think
some of them
maybe for pr reasons don't want to say
hey yeah
we there's all these accounts at our
bank yeah yeah yeah yeah right so
sometimes i know other times i don't
there's a couple videos i don't know
which one uh off the top of my head but
there's times where
in the middle of the call they'll tell
me
go to the bank wire the money
i report the bank
i pretend to drive to the store or sorry
pretend to drive to the bank
and then when i'm there 10 20 minutes
later they're saying uh don't use that
account
wow interesting so sometimes it's
happened very quickly
other times
i just don't know
is that
is that a big detriment to them for an
account to be closed or is it super easy
just to open more
yeah i think it depends so sometimes at
one point i was told that about 90
percent of the accounts that i'm getting
are
at least when their personal accounts
not that
business accounts because sometimes
they'll give me
a business account
like 90 percent 95 of them are victims
it's some old
some some
whoever it is
so
not to go back to too much of the
statistics because i do think and
definitely support it is a common
mission misconception that only old
people get scammed but
with the statistics
i do think that potentially the
elderly population might not be as
represented in those statistics because
they don't even know to report it
right
so a lot of these accounts
they have
direct access to someone's laptop
their their driver's license their bank
account
they have everything and then they ask
me to wire money to it so they can
log in and launder it right that's
crazy i would never even think of that
those guys are so devious man
um
let me ask you this because you're
wasting a colossal amount of people's
time you said 44 hours was the most do
you ever feel bad for them
oh
good question
i there have been times where in
in hindsight like this you played the
video in the beginning steve mm-hmm
uh one of the angriest
or the angriest games i'd probably talk
to
but
uh like there i had to edit some stuff
out of that video where he was saying he
he would like take my husband and
spear his skull oh my goodness nether
region
you edit it out because it's just too
vulgar you'll get demonetized or do you
think it's just
vulgar because i would love to hear that
[ __ ]
you know what i mean i probably have the
original recording i mean it was live
originally
so on twitch people got the whole thing
yeah yeah
but um i remember
after the fact thinking
what
happened to that
guy to like
to be in that situation where losing out
on the 500 well i was probably
2 000 and that's a [ __ ] load of money to
them right i mean sure yeah
um but there's another video
i'm not trying to plug everything uh
able was the scammer's name
i
he was
there's a there's a point where he
i think we spent similar amount of time
maybe at 10 11 hours
he was very
collected and professional
most of the time but when i redeemed
the card he lost it it was almost like
he was crying and just complete like he
completely
everything was shattered for him over
the 500
card and in hindsight or looking back
and watching it
there's
i do have that
moment where i say man like what
what happened what's going on in his
life yeah
yeah um
he can get that that upset about it but
yeah that's i mean it's hard to feel bad
for those people you know but
yeah i don't um
yeah i i don't
think it justifies uh scamming or not
some some old lady but i do try to
remember
uh when i can
that uh
they're it's a it is a person and one
way or another
uh they got to that point but
i still like to make them angry have you
ever
have you ever like built a relationship
with one of these guys
because you talk with them for a long
[ __ ] time in character you guys are
sharing personal stuff with each other
really because i feel like they're
incentivized to try to bond with you to
feel like you're obligated to them in
some way but have you ever actually like
built a relationship with one of these
guys where they're like calling you
checking in on you
yeah something unexpected like that
i've also gotten married to them before
oh a marriage
how did that work
yes uh
well it was mostly joking like it was
obviously not a legal marriage but they
they would go the romance angle wow
yeah and so i would have a friend or
someone
pretend to be the
um
what would you call it the person who
marries you yeah the whatever
yeah yeah yeah
but yeah occasionally like the guy
who's been gone for 44 hours
uh actually he's pretending to be joe
biden at this point
what
wow yeah dude that's awesome
yeah so
but they will occasionally just like
they added me on whatsapp you know and
they'll just message like hey rich my
name's richard um so well
at least according to that this
particular uh scenario like hey rich how
are things going
uh how's business
right uh but there's there's all kinds
of times where they'll call in and check
up but it's
ulterior motives uh they just they they
don't they don't care about you that's
sad yeah
yeah no they don't not even uh the chat
is asking on on the marriage route
people are asking about the time
you flirted with the scammer and got him
to show his face on camera
do we have thanks for bringing that up
because i forget
can we pull a clip of that
i'd love to see it i have done that um a
few times
perhaps one of the more awkward moments
too was
uh
going to my parents house where a bunch
of my extended family were watching
a video like that and i was flirting
with it
with the scammer but
um
yeah i play this character let me know
if it comes through
it should be something like this yeah
yeah yeah hopefully you can hear it
wait can i hear it without the filter
oh yeah yeah i think it's sort of like
this oh that's so good it works yeah i
gotta see how realistic dude i got to
say of all the p i i love this content
you definitely have the best [ __ ]
voice changer game
like your impressions
and the way that you kind of like talk
between the characters is so convincing
it's so good
yeah i appreciate that i've it's been a
lot of practicing and a lot of a lot of
fun for sure but
yeah so that that character
uh nevaeh
is her name have been spelled backwards
she
um
yeah we've done oh gosh
i think at least three of them have
wanted to video chat me here's the one
with you flirting
uh
oh it's 40
yeah i hear we're good i want to see
this a lot yeah i was gonna say a lot of
them are longer because
it ends up when you have 44 hours right
what do you do how do you make it oh
yeah that's three minutes
right but so oh you you're playing oh
damn bro you got all
you got all glammed out
oh yeah so you showed him the webcam
yeah this is before i could like figure
out how to deep fake so
wait i just straight up put makeup on
and everything can you pull up the deep
fake too i want to see what that looks
like so do you show him like a pixelated
feed here so he can't see the fine
details
yeah does he see hd
no it's it's so the top
smaller version is what holy [ __ ] that's
so good
that was probably the first time that i
ever
did it so it's just a learning it's a
learning process do you think this guy
was ready to do a 90-day fiance with you
well
so he
the minute that i went on camera with
him his everything changed like he was
very like flirty he was into it
oh yeah until i went on camera and then
he was really confused and was i think
he just didn't
he wasn't sure what was going on anymore
uh he could tell that it was maybe yeah
yeah that's what let's take a look
can you hear me sam
yeah can you hear me
hey david can you hear me
i can hear you
hi how are you
i'm fine
i was trying to call you like all day so
can he see your feet at this point
yeah yeah i think so okay
it took me like three hours to do that
makeup though so that could have been
i had no clue what i was doing i was
just dude you look clean man you look
great
stop it you look great
thank you
can you show me your feet clearly
because i cannot i cannot see you
probably yeah he needs a question i'm
sorry what did you say
i cannot see you properly
i'm right here hello
i'm so nervous i was nervous too because
i had never done it before yeah it's
scary you want it to work i want this to
work
i'm ready to get him a k1 visa and do a
[ __ ]
whole reality show on this
bringing scammers out to america dude
that'd be the best
there's literally well i don't think
it'll work out but that guy pretending
to be joe biden was hinting at that but
i don't think i don't think it'll work
out no
man are you sure give love a chance
yeah is this not working either my
brother helped me set it up
hello
he's
he's just staring at me david where have
you been all afternoon
oh [ __ ] he's tripping out he's freaking
out right now yeah
yeah it usually doesn't last long after
the video calls although
in uh in more recent time with the
the deep fake type
you know face alteration stuff they have
been a little bit more
um they believe it a lot better here's
here's the face uh
whatever deep fake i'm really curious to
see this one yeah hello oh [ __ ] that
looks awesome oh yeah it looks a little
funky but it looks it's a little weird
yeah yeah that one oh that's crazy that
must trigger them
might not be exactly what they see but
it definitely looks
a little better than
yeah because they're yeah
oh my god that's crazy i love the
lengths you're going to fool these guys
yeah and so some of them
oh yeah this guy this guy can see your
feed
okay let's help you is this
pope nathan
right this is
no i've been trying
because he's gonna you're a hard man to
get a hold of oh now that looks really
good actually i doesn't look that funny
i was told if you go back in the video
not to you know direct it to you too
much but i think there's a point towards
the beginning where he pulls up my
webcam
i mean like back a little bit or back to
the beginning of the video like here
maybe maybe like
i don't know there's like seven minutes
in
i'm guessing
oh okay
oh here's i can see this is the most oh
yeah there's a spike yeah there you go
just use that okay they're perfect
perfect stay there
there you go i got it
oh is he taking photos of you yeah oh
[ __ ] and i can't keep my face
is my computer and my bank safety
move your tear backwards or you're gonna
move your chair backwards
move a little bit away from the camera
so we can get your tie and we can show
you a tie to your girlfriend right to
move back a little bit sit back sit back
lean back a little bit okay
about perfect stay there perfect perfect
stay there
there you go i got it
ah oh excuse me
i had to sneeze
did you get another one
oh that's good
is that what he's screenshotted
so what's he doing he's just trying to
steal your identity yeah you know it's
it's hard because
most of what i do is try to put them
through
absurd situations kind of just to see
like how far will they go
um
and so in that particular scenario
i told him that i had fallen in love
with this random girl that i met when i
clicked one of the ads that said sexy
singles in my area
and so i said that i wanted to get
married to her and he was helping me
like take pictures of this whole weird
scenario wow
yeah so i'm going back to the one where
you uh
dressed up like a lady
here's the most replayed part so let's
watch this part
why can't you just show me
oh my gosh please i'm trying to figure
it out
i had asked david for proof that he
didn't scam me and obviously he wasn't
delivering
sam you cannot share my screen due to
the ethernet connection
why don't you understand
okay
send me a picture right now give me your
email address
like this is like uh towards it's like
middle ish oh okay oh it's right before
the video chat yeah i think it's because
we were we were kind of flirting
and i was confused about whether or not
he was being honest with me and that was
the why can't you like i want to see you
i need to see you so yeah
well you just took a little video of
yourself saying sorry
and send that to me too
[Music]
hi sam
oh this is david i'm really sorry that
by any way if i heard you alone i'm
really sorry
again i'm sorry
i'm sorry
so what's going on here is he what is he
apologizing for
he's is he just trying still to get
money or is this a romantic connection
oh
i don't remember is the honest answer i
guess this is from two years ago yeah
yeah there's so many things that happen
it's hard i
i know that with that one i believe with
that one i had also
pretended that i had lived with my
grandparents
and so
it could have been in some way related
to uh
like my grandparents being confused
about a scam or something
yeah it's hard to keep track of
sometimes
i think one of my favorite
uh
like little moments
where i got a scammer to do something
silly
like apart from the them being really
angry in the google play redeems was
you've probably heard of r slash
choosing beggars yes
and
one of the scammers was upset that i
wouldn't get him enough money and so i
told him if he took a picture of himself
following him i saw that that's crazy
can you guys pull that up
i don't know if it
i don't know if it even was posted on
that reddit now that i think about it
but
so how do you how do you find the
scammers do you wait to get a pop-up on
a website do you wait like how do you
get
this scammer to reach out to you
yeah i
there's a bunch of different ways um
in the beginning
it was more
hunting
them down to try to find
sketchy looking websites
um
like you know there would be people who
would pretend to be dell computer
support and they would buy a domain name
like official dell computer support okay
that's a good place yeah right
so that's how i would do it in the
beginning
um but as time went on and i i started
buying phone numbers and
i would get on all these lists
right
um if anytime the scammers talk to me
if they can't scam me they'll just sell
my number to somebody else oh
you get you're in the funnel now
yes the calls and the call the calls are
just pouring into your numbers
yes wow but people in the community send
them in too so they'll say like my
grandma got this weird email so i get i
don't know a dozen or two submissions
every day so you guys
how many calls do you get a day between
all your numbers
i don't know uh
like we're talking hundreds
that's a good question
that guy steve that you showed earlier
with the um
i wanna make sure i get this right i oh
no no okay a different story
i had spent 33 or 36 hours with a group
of scammers
and i know at one point i think we
i don't want to misquote this but a
thousand calls is in my mind whoa
i don't i don't want to misquote it
though so let's just say a couple
hundred calls so this guy well let's
just say a thousand it's better for the
story it's okay
this guy called you a thousand times one
dude
well like over the course of weeks
so i would damn your phone was just
non-stop ringing from this guy right and
so what i would i would just oh
yeah someone messaged me and said like
fifteen hundred so
i think
the idea though would be something like
you know i'm an old i think i was an
older uh woman for that call
and i would
they'd they'd be saying go to the bank
or or go get gift cards and i'm like i
can't it's my it's my grandson's
birthday and i'd hang up and i would
leave right because it's six o'clock or
whatever and
i'm gonna go eat dinner
but i would come back and i would have
missed 200 calls or something
then just that's intense
nonstop yeah
wow they're so desperate to get that
money it's scary
they're well they're willing to do and
go to any length right i mean it seems
like they don't care who it is what they
have to do what they have to say what
their
conditions are
um yes no empathy sometimes it's scary
yeah yeah
um there's been i think that i have met
um what was the term be sociopaths yeah
i think i've met some people who just
have zero capacity to feel for another
human being which is a little bit weird
uh
we've had scammers threaten to kill me
but they seem
pretty serious yeah there's uh
like like they just they don't even care
that they're telling some crying old
lady that they're gonna come to her
house and kill her jesus
um
yeah it's there's some
some sketchy ones
but we try to make light of it sometimes
too where
i had a guy
pretend to be arnold schwarzenegger
i had a guy
well the one pretending to be joe biden
the way that happened is
um
i was
an
older old man i got a call from someone
who said they were from the ftc
and so i was saying the scammers on the
line with me trying to scam me and i
would say something like well i don't
know i'm getting this other call from
from the ftc i'm going to put him on the
line and then i would i said
hi my name is ftc frank i'm not calling
about you
whatever
yeah
and he built so these scammers thought
that
uh
this old man was falling for another
scam so good
if i'm spelling this out correctly yeah
and then
i
he's like there's no way this guy works
for the ftc no way this guy works and i
go
uh well hold on i'll get kamela harris
on the line let me get kamela and so
then i'm playing multiple characters
pretending to be the vice president and
he he says
hold on let me get the president and and
just
pretends to be joe biden
and at that point i have to yeah
pretend to believe him so i mean for the
for months now he's just pretending to
be joe biden oh my god goodness gracious
yeah that is incredible by the way here
i have the post of the guy posting a
photo
to choosing beggars yeah here it is
so he sent you the image
oh yeah there's nothing
it looks like
see i'm not
you know it right you know it i'm not
gonna explain it to you
okay
you tell me
you are going to give it to me or not
right i mean
it
i think
i might have cropped a tattoo on his
hand i can't remember oh okay but but
yeah it looks like he probably didn't
like smile with his face or anything
like that but
um
yeah there's been some funny ones well
there's not much there's not many
opportunities to do something as
entertaining as this and as good as this
so
we love it uh we're fans here
i love your videos man it's so fun
kit boga
on all social medias right twitch
twitter
instagram so sometimes it's kit boga
show but get boga show kid boga on
twitch which is your primary uh platform
is that right or or youtube
yeah twitch and youtube is almost the
way it pretty much works is uh
like there's 44 hours let's say of me
talking to the guy on twitch
but we edit them down uh
for youtube and uh godspeed to your
editors
well we're putting yeah we're putting
that one off because uh there's just so
much but well keep it up man you're
doing god's work and it's you're just so
funny and good at it so we love you
thank you thank you
thank you for sharing your story with us
kid pogba ladies and gentlemen
yeah i appreciate it i was gonna say we
could uh
try to call some scammers but they're
they're late it's too late the banks are
closed so they
close out what happens but maybe someday
maybe someday so they really stop
calling once the banks close
there's probably a few open but
the most of them
it's like well they're not going to be
able to wire me money they're not going
to be able to
yeah yeah that makes sense because you
stream relatively early in the day and i
always wondered about that i guess that
makes sense that you're you're
accounting for the time difference
yeah and they their primary
the target right is we got to figure out
how to get someone hooked so they can
get to the bank and wire us money before
right it was closed um
[Music]
well thank you guys it was fun and uh
have a good rest of the day thank you
dude thanks for calling god bless that's
kit
boga ladies and gentlemen kit boga
on twitch and youtube
doing god's work and delivering laughs
at the same time who can say that
besides me
uh you can say that that's right but um
no he he's he's a king uh
my girlfriend and i um we'll just put on
his videos at home and it's just
playing in the background and i'll just
be dying laughing like he's unbelievable
at it so if you haven't if you haven't
checked him out please go go check him
out over on twitch
um meanwhile
we've got was there something here a
love got arrested on stream this was
something i was desperate to talk about
oh yes um love was streaming
and and what happened you got pulled
over by the police
yeah i was doing just a little bit of a
fika stream you know
every number uh and i guess i had too
much figure
no what is that well
no no
well uh when i was about to leave
because i usually stream a little bit
when i drive i just put the camera up
and i just talk
and
i ended up being behind the
big police van and
they kind of waved me by and then they
followed me for like 15 minutes or
something like that crazy super weird
and i was driving super slow or a little
bit careful as you do when the police
bind you
and
then they left
so and then i parked to talk with chat a
little bit about it and then they kind
of just kept circling around the block
and ended up pulling me over
and uh
they wanted
that seems so odd because it's 4am so i
guess there's not many people out darn
it yeah did they think you were drunk
is that you're like it's late at night
you're kind of driving slowly and
starting and stopping like that that
does kind of seem like from their point
of view they didn't see me start and
stop really uh they just followed me
they just saw me drive around but i mean
i think it's fair that they wanted to
pull me over but my the issue is that
they followed me for so long they kind
of cased me i thought that was kind of
just unnecessary if they want to stop me
they could have because in sweden they
can do like routine checks without
suspicion oh okay but they don't have
guns or anything you're not like afraid
of them like we are here right i mean of
course they have guns oh they have guns
there
yeah do they kill people here do they
just [ __ ] kill people there of course
not i mean yeah that's different that's
a special american treat
yes it's very i was i wanted to be very
clear for the american viewers when i'm
streaming uh it's very different i was
never afraid for my life or anything
like that that's a shame
right right that has excitement i'll be
honest if a cop was following me at 4 am
for 15 minutes i'd be [ __ ] oh i'll be
here dude very scared so stressful those
guys are storm troopers man
he said like he said oh sorry
he said like the classic quote he said
it's suspicious that you're driving
around at night okay that's pretty
pretty epic you know driving your car at
night
not legal
automatically suspicious so wait where
were you where were you driving to
well i i had been
i was at a parking lot with like lights
where i where i used to go uh so people
can see me because my because i want to
and i was eating they didn't and then i
left and i was just basically driving
home through the city
and they just ended up following me for
a while i i actually get pulled over a
lot especially when i do this stream but
afterwards because i don't i don't know
for whatever reason
they're out patrolling at night when i
do the fika streams let's have a look
this is love
yeah being arrested
he's handcuffed
yup
uh alyssa by the way has a confession
thank you for the donation
you all think abe is on a trip back home
but i personally personally witnessed
him
meet with those two cops in sweden
in an effort to bribe them to take care
of love thoughts
that that adds up yeah that sounds like
maybe
that's some slytherin
here is love ladies and gentlemen
being murdered in his car by the swedish
police
hello
are you allowed to record the police and
stuff in sweden
yeah yeah
people are saying the police are clout
chasing
see there's like multiple cops up on
your [ __ ] four
four cops
yeah rod and cop were you kind of happy
you were getting pulled over because
it's kind of entertaining for the stream
right
um
halfway through i i
concluded yeah because this is good
content
yeah
what are they they're just asking for
your driver's license
you should let people know
this
he has a speaker a bluetooth speaker
hooked up to a guy
and so we just heard this moment ago
that bro that sounded like cops could
hear the cops can hear that and they
will hear everything that's about to
happen that's playing on my bluetooth
speaker it's like it's loud
it's almost louder than what it should
be it's like really loud you have the
jbl cranked right
uh oh yeah totally crying do they ever
comment on the sound bites coming
through your speaker
yeah so
uh they i guess one of them were was
familiar with the type of stream was
doing and they he asked me are you
streaming and i said yeah
at that point i can't because you you
get like even in sweden you get a a lot
of adrenaline when you get pulled over
every time like it's nerve-racking
uh
but after at that point and i saw they
starting to smile after they heard all
the bras and the farts and then i'm like
okay yeah this is content that's
interesting
yeah if that happened here the cop i
think would pepper spray you and then
ask questions later
right right right
did you hear that bro he said he was
going to kill me
tase him
i'm blowing
the bunk
so
so wait people donate and they can
decide what sound to play
it's free
oh okay so how do they decide what sound
to play
uh there's channel points you get for
watching oh [ __ ]
and they can play any sound they want or
no no they're from a bucket
[Laughter]
are you stressing when you're hearing
these sounds are you
no i'm loving it oh my god it's awesome
and i'm i'm like at this point i'll just
[ __ ] shove the camera in their faces
i asked do you want to say hi and he
said no when he backed up
oh [ __ ] that's fine
what's happening
i don't have to say it's not gonna
happen they seem nice man they didn't
even threaten to kill you yet
literally [ __ ] followed me dude so
[ __ ] up okay
[Music]
wow
the bunk is just so funny is that the i
try to think but nothing happens yeah no
it's like uh i don't know i don't know
if that's the same this is just typical
soundbite uh
but yeah i was kind of stressed i had a
lot of adrenaline so i said dogs and i
wish i didn't because i
like those police were obviously
professional they kept the time like
they kept it to a minimum the the one
thing i i was kind of sussed out to was
that they followed me for so long i
thought that was unnecessary sketch
yeah dude you shouldn't have called them
dogs you should call them pigs wait you
call them dogs
yeah
to their face
no oh is that is that like a slur
against police in sweden
nope i just call them dogs because here
we call them pigs you know that right
yeah we say in sweden we say pigs too we
say uh police please talk to this it's
like a rhyme yeah
i just looked up on google images or
google translate i got a message for the
swedish police fan
greaser
how's my swedish fan e greasars love
says um
[ __ ] in pigs yeah
pigs funny cats
yo
you even got an article written up about
you dexter yeah
this went super viral it's super weird
you about to get a blue checky
you're definitely checking so wait when
you when you say it went super viral i
know that oh here's the highlight
young fika
fifty thousand views i mean it went on
red it's not me
well hold on because what the really big
brick you had
right your dear god
juicer himself
me
the one man you'd leave you'd leave me
for
if that's not true that's not true you
come on you let him milk your prostate
be honest sure
sure but that's another thing
jesus well here he is xqc one of the big
i mean if not the biggest streamer
yeah in the world
probably the biggest
watch is the young fico clip guys let's
go
whoo
what is this
incredible commentary too may i say yeah
he really killed it oh yeah from friend
of the show xqc ladies and gentlemen
i can see why he's the number one
streamer
me too
so much to say what is that
[Music]
the farts are going to get him come on
xqc
come on
that's it that's all you got
he's a reaction wait i didn't i didn't
even see the smile wait hold on hold on
he needs to write square harder hold on
this is small
right here
okay okay
wow love
bro
big moment for love
in fact
i think we need to make a shirt out of
this for love make it an emoji we need
to let's go
more immortal like a slightly slack jaw
that sounds awesome
you react
listen that
when it comes to xqc this is huge
commentary he cracked a little bit tiny
bit of a smile yeah that he doesn't do
that to anything you know that's all for
you brother
proud to be a swede today today we're
all swedes
yes
is that the swedish national anthem
oh yeah
god bless sweden
you know we made xqc crackers
yes oh hell yeah brother today we are
all swedes
indeed young figure thank you for the
three gifts thank you for the gift thank
you bonnie
that would be epic and if nina watched
this that would be peace that's real
maybe he will know you right there maybe
maybe it's a viral moment
yeah you guys
you guys stuck all the time right in his
chat yeah i mean we're we buddy buddies
i haven't broken the news to him yet but
i will yeah yeah he'll see it you'll see
it yeah i wonder i'm very excited about
that dexter article i'm not gonna lie
that might be my [ __ ] right there on
fire yeah
yeah damn bro
so we have our very own uh young fika
here twitch
yeah yeah farts down with the police
ladies and gentlemen incredible yeah
so when i was when i was getting pulled
over people in chats like actually said
don't do sound bites can i defend me
because
they're probably used to like where's
police right but there's this one dude i
viped him in my shot he said he spent
eight thousand fijia coins
and spammed uh 80 farts
during that uh what a legend i mean i
mean you owe it all to him really
yeah i mean everything
because of him yeah 80 000 fico coins
what's that usd 8 000. that's a that
translates around to
2.5 mil yeah whoa
wow
think about it
well we have up next alex jones but
how long we've been going here dan
we have been going for two
and a half hours just shy two half hours
i don't know if i should get into this
now because it's so good
because you could do it on leftovers
certainly
loves talking about alex jones
we already have a lot to talk about
tomorrow too though that's what i'm
afraid of it's like so jam-packed
the alex jones thing is almost becoming
old news at this point hassan
picker
we have other stuff
dude alex jones is such a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] i'm so glad
this guy's getting creamed
hit this has been kind of like as bad as
it possibly could have gone for him i
don't i don't think it could have been
worse ditch um
the worst thing pretty much
it is yeah it's kind of hard to imagine
and how it could have gone worse
the worst the worst thing
was
that his lawyer
i'm trying to find the clip of that here
uh you the lawyer uh turning over the
messages by accident yeah
right
here
oh
it's a big one yeah so the worst moment
for him was this one by far
and i mean it's hard to underestimate
his lawyer accidentally sent his entire
phone record
to uh the plaintiff
and it's hard to
overstate just how [ __ ] he is from
this
because first of all
the january 6 commission has subpoenaed
that now
and my favorite his ex-wife his ex-wife
as well has subpoenaed that i guess for
custody or whatever maybe he lied about
his finances
and he's so [ __ ] cooked here like
alex jones is such a little [ __ ] he'll
lie he'll scheme he'll say whatever he
can and he tries to wiggle his way out
of this [ __ ] you could see but he's so
[ __ ] sucking a ding-dong
and apparently there's texts with
senators in there
i mean this is two and a half years of
every thing he talked about on his phone
text with tucker carlson in there we
haven't even began to really understand
that that's the one that
got me i mean real excited a senator and
talker are texting with alex jones how
[ __ ] demented are these people
they're sick quite they're quite
demented so here is this moment which
honestly is just
we don't get things like this every
often we have to enjoy this this is a
once in a lifetime experience here it
really is incredible
nice trick
yes wait it starts kind of late
uh no this is this is the moment so you
dig yeah no but
if you i want to
to show a little bit before this was
some good [ __ ] like a minute before this
when he asked do you know how i got your
records that's in there that's what i'm
trying to say
so you did get my text messages
and they said you didn't nice trick
yes mr jones
indeed
you didn't give this text message to me
you don't you don't know where this came
from do you know where i got this no
mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged or protected
in any way
and as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession and that is how
i know you lied to me when you said you
didn't have text messages about san
diego did you know that
i see i told you the truth this is your
apparent national moment i gave you a
nice try
and then mr jones you need to answer the
question
no i don't know this happened but i mean
i told you i gave him the phone over and
just said no
you said question you said in your
deposition
you searched your phone
you said you pulled down the text did
the search function for sandy hook
that's what you said mr jones correct
and i had several several different
phones with this number but i did yeah
well folks i mean that's why you got it
bro he's so
it's like a 12 year old lion yeah the
cookie jar oh my god [ __ ] cooked it's
so
embarrassing but it's it's it's like but
life ruining i mean he is panicking
right now and not only that so basically
they've proved that he's perjured
himself twice he's lied under oath
provable several times in this and i i
think he might actually be in criminal
trouble now too because of that i mean
if they choose to go after it from what
i understand
perjury isn't prosecuted that often but
i mean he's a big enough piece of [ __ ]
that they might just throw the book i
say go off yeah i think they probably
will
could be my lawyer said it to you but
i'm hiding them right it's such a like
such a [ __ ] it's such a like middle
schooler in the counselor's office like
denying reality i mean he's saying my
dog ate my homework
yeah i love the opposing counsel he's
like
okay mr jones well
and he's i mean he's like the only guy
who really is ever going to get to do
that to him and
i'm glad he reveled in it
yeah hearing that he did that right wow
just incredible
but he really tries to just lie like a
little [ __ ] as always oh see my lawyers
did send it to you that's how you got it
it's like obviously that's not what he
means yeah and in it it proves you lied
mr jones
mr does us just answer questions there's
no question
mr benson also only asked questions sure
mr jones in discovery you were asked do
you have sandy hook text messages on
your phone and you said no correct
he's like uh-oh
what do i say he knows he knows i got
him
any further you know what it is yes i do
i mean i'm not attracted
to i gave in my testimony the phone to
the lawyers before whatever and and so
you've got my phone
one more time
okay please remember if you need to a
certain put them in you can't i mean you
can do that i love that he said that too
if you need to plead the fifth just go
ahead and do it [ __ ]
but you testified
yeah mean the whole honestly the whole
thing is great it's a little cut out
from the front and end but if you want
the whole thing it's easy to find on on
youtube and stuff man it really is
rare that we get a dub this big these
days like you were saying at the
beginning of the episode and
this last week
it's just so much finally been some good
news you know it's it's nice you love to
see it
yeah
the other thing is uh well god bless
america today this week dark brandon
[Music]
brandon2024
and not only that we have co-opted
brandon
let's [ __ ] go brandon what a loving
liberal it's ours now
but there's actually so many great
moments um in the trial
it's just a train wreck for him the
whole time
um and by the way his lawyer who his
lawyer must be an agent or he must be an
asset i mean how do you [ __ ] up that bad
his lawyer sent him on accident
two and a half years of text messages
then the opposing counsel is required to
tell him hey you sent me this
so hope they can try to do some motions
to say it's private or something to keep
it from entering evidence
uh what he responded was basically oh
sorry just disregard that
and after there's a certain period of
time where they can use it as evidence
their you know window to appeal it
closes
and he didn't even try to keep it
private now
alex is probably going to sue the [ __ ]
out of his
lawyer he probably should that's crazy
malpractice it's his what like fifth
attorney i think that's the thing is i
think he's really scraping the bottom of
the barrel what was the name of uh henry
winkler's character in arrested
development like the worst [ __ ]
lawyer yeah he ever messed with people's
hands right
he needs to get blah blah blah is that
or is that sunny
oh maybe that is sunny yeah that's uncle
jack you're thinking of it yeah but yeah
there's
no way like this is this is back of the
phone book
back of the yellow pages lawyering right
here blah blah blah yeah yeah i mean
alex jones has a shitload of money they
reveal in his text messages because
again he kept lying about how much money
he was making to try to reduce damages
and in the [ __ ] text messages he was
bragging about making eight hundred
thousand dollars in a single day
from selling his [ __ ] supplements ah
so we gotta get on that [ __ ] dude no
selling some [ __ ] podcasts we're
selling uh
we're selling metamucil uh brain brain
uh brain enhancers
yeah welcome to watching the hd podcast
today uh the government is trying to
read your mind this pill here will block
your mind from a government raise
uh three easy payments of 199.
you know how uh hassan has his like
trucker like red blood america hank
pecker or whatever like his alter ego i
think you need one of those like what is
what
what is the
the uh
southern i want to be branded
there's got to be a play on ethan klein
though is what i'm saying like uh well
let's see ethan uh what's like a nathan
united eugene climb i'm nathan claim
klein is too vaguely jewish
yeah i've got to be like a k another
like kilgore i'm how about how about
nathan clan
that's pretty good but there's got to be
someone with the last name klansman
right
the other has to be dude that's such a
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] up name i'm
nathaniel klansman bart
come on by our bucket of slop
the world is ending you don't want to be
caught without dried beans
all you got to do is add water boy
i got here a bucket of
pig semen so you can repopulate the
earth with some of them
and if all goes to [ __ ] you can drink it
packed with vitamin d
protein
all kinds of nootropics
i drink this every morning
800 000 in a day
yeah i mean i think they even
said that that was in a good day um
but yeah i mean
okay
on the on the best day of the h3 podcast
i can tell you all right now we have not
made a fraction of 800 those are those
are sam temple numbers right there yeah
maybe today
maybe today what do we have by the way
on the cheap one on the back end it says
5.8 k
wow
[Applause]
she coming out here with the new jeep
ladies and gentlemen in be walking us in
he be walking to work i told him i'd buy
him a new skateboard
generous queen a horse maybe just new
trucks okay but that one's for the jeep
okay so yeah don't even don't buy him
from that yeah yeah
you can't dip in the
just some new trucks would be plenty
generous ian
get your own donors yeah these are sams
i can't believe that happened man sam
ladies and gentlemen
here they come again there's a lot of
love for sam out there sam
god damn it
everyone is very sweet
it's very nice
how much again again
uh
5.8 k 5.8 k show sam
let's say it again
5.8 k
[Music]
wow
that's jeep money right there ladies and
gentlemen
now i thought it was a joke at first you
know i was like oh 100 bucks
damn girl's about to roll up in a jeep
can you take zach and maybe we can film
a whole little segment out of it
for sure i want to see zach in action
are you free tomorrow zach interesting
uh yeah no he's not we're working in the
morning well thursday in the morning but
then we'll go in the afternoon afternoon
actually no i have a doctor no
friday what another toe thing no
therapy oh that's good friday gotcha
love that for you
love that yeah same temple the gifted
sub thank you for the gifted
and thank you to uh
what is that 2500 50
50 gifted subs what's the 250 mean
i don't know
maybe that's his total 25. has he really
given that much
no way it's been that many well maybe i
don't know it's always coming
at the time yeah maybe you're right it
does add up quick that is a lot holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh dude that's so true wait
let me just ask him i'm in contact with
him now why don't you guys bring that's
so true you guys can bring gabe gabe
with you to the dealership yeah oh give
me a better price
baby
he said yup milestone 2500 like wow
that is kind of saudi arabia
[Applause]
another hundred dollars for sam get that
jeep sam what and on earth is happening
you guys
you guys are something else man actually
oh my i guess i'll i'll show this on the
show our saudi prince uh
sent this to me the other day daddy cash
oil
love that for you
he made that so shout out all of a
sudden i love fracking build the pipes
build the pipeline
this is nathaniel klansman i say build
the pipes
we need more oil nathaniel clansman
maybe just clan
nope i'm a clan's been dying
it was my poppy's name and my papi
before him i didn't take my surname for
nobody i'm a clients man
threw it through damn it oh man earl
that do you like earl or nathaniel i
like nathan that's my given name
that's my god-given name god gave me
that name i ain't never changed
hi my name is nathaniel klansman and i
hate blokes
did i fool anyone i was going to say
i was trying to bait you guys like i was
saying something else but
it didn't work
thank you you guys want to keep talking
about alex jones there's uh
there's so much i mean
they're so the judge tells them to stop
lying that's pretty great
mr jones
you may not say to this jury
that you comply with discovery
that is not true
you may not say it again
you may not tell this jury that you are
veteran that is also not true that's so
awesome do not they have filed for
bankruptcy
i don't know that but i've heard that it
doesn't put that doesn't make a person
or a company bankrupt
you're already under oath to tell the
truth
you've already violated that oath twice
today
in just those two examples
it seems
absurd to instruct you again that you
must tell the truth while you testify
yet here i am you must tell the truth
while you testify
this is not your show
you need to slow down
and not take what you see as
opportunities
to
further the message you're wanting to
put her
and instead
only answer
the specific
and exact question you have been asked
she was so over his ass was that the
part where he goes well i i believe
that's true and she goes just because
you believe it's true
doesn't mean and it is that's why we're
here today and of course because he's
learned absolutely no lessons and isn't
capable of growing in any way
um he has been attacking this judge on
the show
um the kind of the crazy all of his fans
have dug up her social media and are
claiming she's biased of course because
she had like you know it's pretty clear
in her personal life she's liberal
leaning um and so they hate that and are
claiming that this is a mistrial because
the judge is corrupt yada yada yada even
though this isn't even the trial i think
that's lost on a lot of people he
already lost this whole thing that we've
been witnessing
was
to determine damages and it was
determined by a jury not by the judge
so
i still don't really understand his
legal strategy because they didn't even
contest the defamation they lost on
default right never responded correct
which is i i don't i i don't get that he
also has another uh up and coming trial
two more two more uh one in connecticut
and is it two in connecticut
i don't know uh at least one is in
connecticut from what i understand
though the connecticut one
um the
caps on
uh damages are even worse than in texas
so he's very unlikely to owe that much
in that connecticut trial i think it's
captain uh oh really yeah it's capped at
like 750 000 or something like that oh
[ __ ] cool well no that's in texas
so maybe it's even less than that i
remember reading that it the the cap in
connecticut is extremely low
um
the craziest thing about this is that
during all this trial he's going back to
his studio
sometimes even when the trials live
right he'll be watching it live from his
studio
and saying that
uh the jury is stupid
that the witness is slow
uh that the judge should be fired and he
accused her of being a pedophile i mean
this is insane yeah he's just i think he
can help it i think he really is it's
his only even look it's it's his only
way all i know are acting with the world
yes that's right it's it's the only way
he is
but i actually think between these three
trials this could really end infowars i
really actually think and i hope i hope
it does you know
my lawyer told me something interesting
he said
the klu klux klan was ultimately
defeated and uh dissolved through a
bunch of lawsuits like this
bankrupted them and then they kind of
just disappeared
yeah a lot of people are awaiting the
new world order
but they're experts in leftist
jurisdictions in sending out
jury
[Music]
summons
and hitting let's just say this
extremely blue collar folks
i mean
half that jury panel just not know who i
am
isn't that the point
right the jury's not supposed to know
who you are
[Laughter]
and also it's like
his whole [ __ ] shtick is like
appealing to
the average man against the elites
against the elite pedophiles blah blah
blah and then all of a sudden it's like
you know if you read between the lines
of what he's saying he's he's calling
them trash dom hicks yeah yeah a bunch
of uneducated hicks yeah who the [ __ ] do
you think your audience is dum-dum
exactly said that
and when they were asked and during the
jury
in paneling yesterday
do you believe the media has ever gotten
anything wrong about alex jones they all
unanimously said no
so
it's people do live in all these
different bubbles and there's the
bubbles that are awake and the bubbles
that are questioning but then there's
the blue city bubbles
where people do not know what planets
blue city bubbles where did this take
place is in texas
i mean some cities in texas are yeah
uh
it's still just
really
sad that even the bluest bubble in texas
a bit yeehaw probably
a little touchy or perhaps a little
touchy yeah but also like you said i
mean the
isn't it good that the jury is unbiased
they don't know who you are like what's
that deal yeah isn't that
a good thing there's a problem when you
have this really famous person on the
stand becomes an issue with jury
selection because the whole point of
jury selection is to find an unbiased
group of people
so
yeah the fact that half the people don't
know him is good why does he i would
assume if people know him it's because
they
it's not good like
if they've heard something about alex
jones
pretty sure it's not going to be a good
thing right
harry is calling the judge a pedophile
this is of course an all-timer
yeah this this strategy did not play out
well for him in court
you've been broadcasting repeatedly
a picture of our judge
on fire haven't you
objection compound your own
no
you have to wait until the court moves
out
um overruled there was a statement and
then a question
can i see it please yes yes you make her
she's like people may i see what the
this picture of me on fire
it's about me
grumpy
wow person on the left of this
judge correct
yes the person on the right is another
judge he literally just said no yes yeah
he's like no it wasn't me
it wasn't me
is this the picture yes
oh god
you know and this poor judge actually i
think judge selection is kind of random
too it is random
and so it's like
now she gonna have to deal with a
lifetime harassment she gonna have to
assume i'm sure it's already happening
it's i'm sure it's already happening
guaranteed
oh [ __ ] him so bad
and by the way let's just never forgive
joe rogan i mean it was like a few
months ago he was like alex jones is
right about a lot of stuff
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] loser
i hate that
all right tone it down ethan
her smile when she sees the photo is
super like boss
she's just like
okay
i mean she's probably like [ __ ]
yeah
love that this is some real
bohemian grove style editings
so crazy
was ironic because he was the one that
exposed the bohemian grove in the 90s
there you have it
um
here's jones uh
oh the verdict being read out this is
good
you think i could squash the beef with
joe rogan not that he gives a [ __ ] about
me but
i don't think he has any beef with you i
don't yeah i don't think he knows about
me but from from my side
i really don't like him i don't know
what to say i a few years ago i would
have said absolutely i
yeah he's uh i feel like he's just he's
dog [ __ ] now i don't know i mean he was
always kind of dog [ __ ] but he would
just seem
like a kind of a lovable stoner dude
yeah you know
um but yeah in the last since covid i
mean i feel like the whole covid
situation just co totally broke his
brain i mean the dude had jordan
peterson on a [ __ ] tuxedo like a
couple months ago
massaging his [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah show up
at work
yeah that's what he said about
people who are well dude what an [ __ ]
show up at work and work harder
that's what he said about the the labor
shortage because nobody wanted to go
back to
work [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you dude he really he actually
really pissed off his own fans with that
there was really
i saw quite a bit of backlash from joe
rogan because
joey
had a normal
he hasn't worked a blue collar job since
he was like 19 years old like he
literally when i was working on on fear
factor i would show up for work every
day
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway here's the verdict
thank
you um obviously this verdict is
unanimous since that's what's required
and i will read the answers
i'm just gonna make sure everything's
filled out properly first
20 million 500 thousand dollars
oh something i should point out
you tell me do you think when she's
reading out this verdict and how much he
owes if she seems like she's gloating
and laughing
because this is a narrative this is a
narrative that's already i see i've seen
it on reddit and twitter from jones
defenders that she's obvious because
they're really upset at this judge again
they think that she's biased and she's a
blm supporting sjw or whatever and she
had it out for jones and they
specifically keep saying that she's
gloating tell me tell me what you think
yeah
let's have a look
by the way even if she was i mean
kind of entitled to after he called her
a pedophile was implying it would be
understandable but i mean you know
that's what judge is supposed to of
course an era of impartiality so
question number one
four million two hundred thousand
dollars
question number two
five hundred 20
dollars
question number three
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
tap dancing on his grave right there
look at me that's as dry as it gets yeah
she looks like she's disappointed
about it not being enough
she doesn't look like she's happy about
it she looks like she's like are you
kidding me he deserves to give more
that's as dry
and impersonal as it gets
in fact she was probably aware of that
possibility and she's just being as
plain
and straightforward as possible is this
your verdict so say
each and all of you
yes
thank you very much uh would the
attorneys like to examine the verdict
all right um then i'm going to accept
this as a verdict of the jury and that's
kind of insane i mean they really can
say anything they want yeah it's just i
mean and then they learn from alex
you just say whatever
man
that's wild
well [ __ ] him
um ultimately he's gonna have to pay
them 4.1 million after
puni there's a punitive damage cap
they they awarded them 45 million
imputative damages but the cap is 750
000. nothing with the prime too bad
um the plaintiff of the family suing him
said they're going to try to get the cap
lifted i don't know how he's going to
try to do that but
uh also the little tidbits that came out
of his text messages are pretty good
so
apparently alex jones sent images of his
own wife naked to roger stone i mean
what the [ __ ] mr john said is that like
a cuck is that a cuck move like
probably more like roger stone actually
famously is a swinger with his wife so
it's more like swinger kind of behavior
well he actually raises a good point
this is the the lawyer for the plaintiff
there was an intimate photo of his wife
on the phone that i can also confirm
that's true and i normally wouldn't talk
about that in public um but there is a
public interest angle into this is that
i'm a little concerned about it because
that intimate photo
was sent to roger stone and i don't know
if that was consensual and if it wasn't
consensual and mrs wolf jones should
know about that and there might be
something that needs to be done about
that then again it could be totally
consensual but when i see that and i
don't see any indication that it was um
i'm i'm concerned something might not be
on the up and up with that there's
that's [ __ ] great juicy i mean
the depths of [ __ ] he's in from this
knock it over my wife cannot be conveyed
here i i found immediately i just
searched alex jones judge on reddit and
one of the top threads is from a
subreddit called free speech
what the quote neutral judge over alex
jones with pictures from her social
media where you know she's
showing support to lgbt and stuff
and then
she couldn't stop laughing as she read
out his punishment what
also a little ironic free speech
subreddit all she's doing is expressing
her right
no if judges can have free speech now
means our ability to lie right and say
whatever the [ __ ] we want without any
critical thinking how can you say that
she was
she couldn't stop laughing she read out
his punishment she couldn't stop
bro
that's nuts what do the comments say
no way his child could be impartial
all right keep going
uh go to the next like main comment
if you think the government is fair and
balanced i have a bridge you should buy
definitely
what no picture of her and her [ __ ] hat
what
i think that was a thing where oh like
the woman from the women's market
oh so she has a heart yeah and [ __ ] too
good thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow how are you that quick
holy [ __ ]
here's alex jones on steve bannon's
podcast begging for money
i will never
give up
i will never sell out but i could give
out just like
anybody could if we don't have support
if people don't visit infowars.com if
they don't share the show they don't
share the articles from band dot video
or our forbidden videos are
then yes we will be shut down but i'd
like to be able to give your huge
audience a basic breakdown of where
we're at
i've never been profit driven
oh my god
[Music]
okay from
that you [ __ ] money goblin troll
[ __ ] you literally sell like
sawdust in a pill form
like half of the show is that dude come
on dude shut
up uh the media puts out all these giant
numbers of hundreds of millions of
dollars that's his tax
said 800 000 in a day not true that's
just completely made up that's over many
many many years
how many gross products we've sold being
self-funded but anybody that sells
products online knows that on average
you make 30 40
on a product so yeah they can use a
number of you know
bro nice try
such a weird spin five six years and say
wow 160 million dollars wait is he
whining that his margins are only 30 to
40 percent well yeah but he goes
isn't that like incredible he's like
there's so many layers of lies he says
well we've made 800 000 in the history
of selling all of our supplements and we
only make 30 of that
so in my year on infowars i've only ever
gotten two hundred thousand dollars of
profit yeah i mean 20 25 years of
broadcasting footwork.com that's cool
he's got 165 million dollars
i will never
give up i will never sell out
about steve bannon but that boy got his
liver spot game is on fire
look at
that looking healthy as always
i will never yeah whatever these guys
are [ __ ] demons oh crazy
folks folks i'm gonna be honest with you
i need the money right now
so this is a special offer to you steve
bannon for the low low price
of five thousand dollars i will milk
your prostate
it'll be the best prostate milking
you've ever received in your heart oh
yeah
let's go
i've read top level documents from
government agents that say i do the best
prostate milking in the industry i
believe it investment wonderful wow
if i can't make it i have a fleet of
lookalikes that will come to your house
we have thousands of people standing by
to milk your prostate i'm selling alex
jones masks right now so you can look in
the mirror and then milk your own
prostate too go to infor's and buy some
alex jones
and while we're there milking your
prostate we will actually bottle your
[ __ ] that's right and resell it repackage
it a lot of vital vital vitamins and
powerful uh protein and superfood
nootropics and that i'm saying comb is a
superfood so if you let us keep your
jizz we will give you a 20
off
and while we're at it by we have this
jizz supplement so your load is 50
bigger
it's been a horse hair
gravel and asbestos real american semen
right here
folks we're also selling uh lube at
infowars.com lube
with the glove for milk and the prostate
we got the whole package here the whole
process
and four stock
we have never been profit driven
oh what the [ __ ] does that mean
cam that's goaded my friend
yeah you have a grip
i let both of my impressions out of the
bag this week i guess it's true yes so
yeah but they're kind of well they're
not the same but they're both gravelly
little right yeah exactly it's that's my
niche i guess yeah according to
reports tucker carlson is [ __ ] his
bed scared about what a text may leak
between him and alex
carlson and the raving infor's uh ranter
trade texts on a daily basis according
to two people familiar with their
relationship daily basis if made public
these sources said the text message
would be highly embarrassing for carlson
can you imagine what's in that oh mama i
can't wait for these
to get leaked they're going to
please
please
oh my god
i want to say whatever tax between me
and epstein are fabricated okay
uh that's another guy his name's epstein
good guy jeffrey epstein he's a cousin
of mine uh yeah he also has an island i
just want you to know
that whatever trips to islands of
jeffrey epstein is uh my cousin also
it's fake it's
calm
my good friend jeffrey epstein's being
crucified by the lame stream media we're
reporting all the truth right here
all right that's all we got hey speaking
of epstein
did you see this is kind of flowing
under the radar but remember
all the stuff with him with his his
plane and the flight logs yeah sure so
you know bill clinton is on there like a
bunch of times and like all these other
celebrities or whatever but even though
trump
was clearly buddies with him i mean it's
that wasn't even a secret he did
interviews where he talked about him and
his friendship with him and everything
he was never on actually on the flight
logs
i guess some documents from
jizzlane's um
trial got unsealed and there was a bunch
of new flight logs
that nobody had seen before and trump is
on those so
that happened like a month or two ago
and that was their that was basically
the conservative defense was just trump
wasn't all done right it wasn't in those
flight logs ah
do we had could we do we have is that
like confirmed 100 yeah yeah yeah
uh
yeah maxwell trial flight logs show
trump flew on lolita express here's a
bunch of articles about what are we
gonna do about it
what are we gonna do why aren't people
talking about that
i mean probably because he was rated by
the fbi yeah but he gives us so much
yeah
but it was actually this information
actually came out a while ago this
wasn't like last week or anything oh man
but i had a beat off i feel like just no
one wants to touch the story because
there's people on all
sides that are implicated you know what
i mean like
if you really want to dig into this
you're also going to expose
uh clinton you know which i say oh i
mean i've had it sure nobody cares about
bill clinton anymore everyone [ __ ]
knows he's a freak he's a creep well
anyway that's about it um
good stuff
good stuff we'll we'll work on getting
so what happens for the trailer thing i
guess we can do that on friday
sure all right nothing's really panning
out with the caller
nothing so far working on it
well guys happy wednesday thanks for
tuning in and congratulations to sam on
her dude
thank you guys what's the total at with
my hyundai so sweet of everyone thank
you sincerely uh the total with your
hyundy as it shows in the back end right
now
is six thousand three hundred dollars
that's crazy what is going on
congratulations sam
uh we're just so happy to be running a
promotion on infowars.com for six
thousand three hundred dollars what we
provide is a fresh specimen of semen uh
from the finest specimens we can you
drink that it's got nootropics it's got
proteins and it's gonna
boost your immunity for the next ten
years six thousand three hundred dollars
it could all be yours infowars.com
thank you for the donut
i think with the donald
thank you for the jeep thank you for the
need
wow what a thing what a beautiful thing
guys thank you everyone for watching
congratulations sam what a wild wild
time we had today wow
um
sam emojis in the chat let's [ __ ] go
right
now it's outdated just red hair now
that's just the magic of the moment we
gotta get kim to photoshop it yeah as
soon as the show ends i'll update it
immediately okay
this my friends is the magic of the
moment only here on the h3 podcast live
number 12 show in the [ __ ] world
and tomorrow morning we will be back
with leftovers with hassan
uh spreading
liberal [ __ ] garbage and uh socialist
propaganda
to the masses
infowars.com what do you think of this
fat game overlay that's not the key it's
nice but i feel like it takes away from
my
birth okay maybe you can move it like in
the top yeah it should be at the top
sure
yeah it's distracting i don't want to
distract from the money maker there
[Laughter]
tomorrow
in addition to measuring hassan's head
we're gonna have to address
some hurt feelings
yeah he's upset about the bff ff
okay well we'll we'll take it head on
you know yeah
that's what we do here that's what we do
we confront a straight shooter y'all are
crazy though i can't believe you guys
donated six thousand dollars to sam just
on a willy nilly
there it is
that's what we do that's what we do
around here
and just to be clear you cannot spend
any of that money on ian that's fraud
absolutely not yet not a penny
that's true
if we find out
with peace and love
[Applause]
i'm gonna take you to danish this
weekend i got one wheels on me bro i can
pick you up like halfway sometimes
if you're like on the way you know
if you need some new screws or some [ __ ]
i got you
five could probably give me the bus
ticket here
i don't know if it covers the way back
okay it's gone up we only need you here
i don't really care if you got it
how about this i'll bring you to work
every day well why does he have to leave
there's a shower here i can set up a
little cot in the attic exactly a lot of
toothbrushes
my concern is when he arrives
that it's prompted on time
the the trip home is not he'll never be
late again yeah
so ian we're gonna hook you up we're
gonna get you a caught a really nice one
and uh we'll set you up buddy don't
worry
you won't have to travel ever again
ian's in my arm just fell off
what's going on
oh no my life is falling apart dude
all right guys listen
thank you everybody we'll see you
tomorrow morning we'll see you on friday
zay street podcast signing out
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
you